you didn't know she morality or a
malefactor challenge on the muhammad
room table before the eleventh hour to
hide in a scene isn't a video prepare a
lot much my cosmic spirit mother alive
you are alive we are alive okay okay but
we do have some latency will see if
someone okay here's one gentleman says
hello the stream health is only medium
for now which is due to my internet
service provider if it's raining or if
it's the bad weather you know it's it's
always the connection lags and it's just
terrible but I hope we'll be able to get
through this stream you know without
without any problems so hello everyone
and we seem to already be having a lot
of people joining in criminal Dino only
forth to say hello I don't know I'm
pretty disappointed I thought he'd be at
least in the top three but alright so
first people to join game junk cubics
Ronaldinho obnoxious who to hit boom
hoof or can't really pronounce that
Erasmus suitors term Andre material and
and so on and so on okay we'll see how
many people joins but we will wait a few
minutes before we start announcing what
exactly we're doing here but yeah for
those of you who know welcome to our
live stream - delicious arena - some fun
and games and - of course
the giveaway probably why you all came
but you know there will also be some
nice chess as usual here is my co-host
Dion Almighty hello young how are you
there are very good things for inviting
me once again and hopefully it would be
another great one yes I I don't see I
think it will be look and here we have
for the first time in the newest member
of the team
this is teen chick how are you okay
and he will be helping us out with some
with some graphics and also he's only
started playing chess for the past week
but he's already becoming quite the
player already broke 1200 unleashes so
not bad and yeah the tournament starts
in 54 minutes and we
have 1400 people but most most of the
people join in after the tournament
already starts so I think we can expect
some three 3,000 people maybe and a lot
of you said that maybe maybe we
shouldn't have prizes because then you
have to you know brawl it out with with
with the title players but it's I feel
like it's just a nice opportunity for
everyone to get a chance to to get a
crack at the title players already to to
Grand Master's have joined mr. Knight
King Alexander botanique and mr. never
enough I don't know who never enough is
do you know who never enough is I don't
but I think we can easily check that
it's nope it's it's it will be a mystery
until the end of the tournament because
you have to if you win the tournament
then you will have to say who you are if
you want to receive the prize okay
but you know I will not publicly
disclose it if if if the Grand Master
doesn't wish so how are you doing is
that brat or brat hope I hope is brat
brother Brett yeah probably right but
yeah a lot of people and we are going to
accept some challenges before the
tournament starts and well you can do
the honors okay so do we want to start
with that immediately or do you want to
talk some more you can you can
challenges and I'm gonna talk all the
time so okay but you have to do it in a
separate tab in a separate tab and the
rule is only casual stuff yeah only
casual games as we are all gonna be
using my account so it wouldn't be fair
okay and I wouldn't want you to lose me
my rating you know my breakfast really
I'm here here okay so we do have some
okay now there's another two days but
roll bullet for the first game casual
both for the person huh
what yeah okay second tab yeah second
tab okay
just yeah you can do that copy okay here
we go there you have it very good the
second step is on well let's start this
bullet
all right Malik Malik in Duarte says
okay let me just fix that because the
volume is a bit too strong okay
[Music]
stream complete
no YouTube it on okay okay I should not
have fixed that okay it's really weird
it's do you guys see us because it says
that the stream is offline for some
reason and the stream really shouldn't
be offline yeah okay there's no pressure
it's it's not rated game but we will
have to figure the stream this is really
really weird yeah okay it went offline
for a second it says just refresh okay
because it still says offline over here
which is very I'm very unimpressed with
YouTube for the past few days they've
been really you know trolling me a lot
of people weren't able to see the video
I posted and then this happens and you
know ok but we'll see after you after we
finish this we will try to refresh it
and see if it works
oops offline ok people are saying it's
offline again what ok they want to fix
that or no I'll finish the game and then
we'll fix it it's really really strange
shouldn't happen
two squares okay let's just check one
okay let's just check this okay stop
streaming no it's still streaming so
it's not a problem in the OBS let's just
refresh this just to check if you guys
aren't rolling me it would be a real
shame
yeah okay something's happening okay we
do have it does say live and the stream
resumed
okay okay medium stuff it's really
strange since this never happened before
and we haven't really did anything
differently so I hope it will work now
really a shame and Yun even lost the
game only because of that yeah it will
happen it would be a swift victory but
still congratulations to mr. Aaron yeah
c25 good game even though I will look
okay but you can't win all of them so
let's continue Jim fine 95 its dripless
so-so
oh that's oh that's a nice nice one a
little bit more time ah
because now it doesn't say stream is
like it says stream resumed the stream
is continuing but okay whatever that
means
okay offline again seriously
okay that's just weird
refresh camp already started with the
jokes okay
I'm investigating this it doesn't seem
to be something I can fix
really really a shame it would be nice
if only the messages throughout the
whole stream would be if you are online
or offline yeah
it's working no but now it's working
it's not a fly okay I I you guys are
just throwing me but seriously I I
really hope it won't come to that
as we spent a lot of time planning this
so it'd be a shame but
you know if it happens it happens yeah I
still can't control the weather
unfortunately give it time give it out
care 1 million subscribers yeah maybe
then maybe then I'll get a decent
internet service provider William
Williams Anita says Chow from Italy
helped suddenly says he doesn't see the
third one because sometimes and he went
away not only not only blocking him but
he also went away yeah we'll see yeah
all right the same as yesterday the same
as yesterday because yesterday some
people couldn't see the video some
people could there was no connection why
some good some white Sun couldn't I
think it will just fix itself if we just
wait okay that's what I usually about
everything but yeah should work yes
thank you thank you for for saying that
it works and I haven't asked but I
presume that you can also hear us you
can also play the Evans gambit if if you
get the opportunity okay all right we'll
do that
yeah nice here in Romania there's a 100
megabits per second upload well I have
50 here but sometimes it's more like 5
so it really depends on the weather
where are the girls coming they are
coming yeah always wait for the chest
part yeah ok so we do have a variation
from the recent Roach's championship
match which I probably didn't play
correctly at least aha all right you
also have the f5 in and yeah do you
sacrifice a pawn that's good which the
e5 wasn't yeah but it's the line without
the supercomputer line you didn't go
Queen b8
no let's let's do something here nice
hairstyle for who that's the question
for who yeah you had a we both had our
haircuts done yeah ago I have mine
when yesterday yeah and it wasn't
because of the stream or anything is it
yeah it needed to be done
yeah at least Lucy though it says what
about us
1200 so we demand our chance to play
well you do have a chance to play any
more than play yeah don't worry about it
anyone can play and everyone is more
than welcome to beat a few grandmasters
that's that's why we're here hopefully a
lot of them will lose and hopefully no
one will cheat as I really hate it but
it always it happens at least once or
twice every tournament also yeah not
just the Evans gambit yes time playing
with the black pieces if somebody has
recommendation what he would love he or
she would like to see me play let me
know with the black pieces well okay
that's good that's not a nice that's the
Queen Jim Jim found it okay
bouquet zero was also a three yeah it's
I think it's the best three plus so and
then we you know you have time for
everything
winger but I know you play wing gambit I
always play the wing gambit I enjoy any
align it might not be five I don't know
no protected threatened defy you don't
play it like that no I just put b5
I shall I seen a book once it was
awesome okay in a pretty strong center I
would say yeah especially if he plays
like that
all together Quinta if I was actually
winning a piece there but okay do you
fit in the stairs yeah the stairs are
quite large there are even too large for
this apartment I would well I would very
much wish that they weren't even here
but you know it was here when I got here
so but they are large
ah truth about the name no it's still
not at the time maybe maybe I don't know
maybe in a different milestone well yes
but that sounds too too far away from
now so we'll see how it goes
yeah I don't know we were just we were
talking and we said that I was on the
fifty string one and a half years ago or
something yeah was I believe that long
ago
yeah but that's like 3:15 and probably
at full g4 ah like a cup of Blanc are
very nice yes he always pushes g4 so
what he can go h6 maybe it doesn't
really do much I'll eat and push f6 yes
and he was the queen well he he doesn't
care about the mate he is going for my
bishop okay let's play f6
why not recapture they need to return
checkmate and the Queen
let's threaten a lot of times and then
yeah you ruined it yeah pretty much
sure thing mr. mr. Lazzaro if we have
indeed played that game I'm very happy
soonish says that if you put our math or
two to the google translator that an
interesting result arises I already
mentioned this once I mean I I once
studied Esperanto for for some week and
I think our motto in Esperanto sounds
something like gamer or player but it
doesn't have anything to do with that
it's just a happy coincidence okay
and I only found that out myself like
maybe a year ago do you consider
yourself a gamer or a player not not
really i I do game and play but I
wouldn't label myself that way
tournament okay tournament starts time
what is where's the dog the dog is
following the third member of our team
as he does have a lot of animals Sookie
he really likes him there they are both
of them but you will only see them in
like 15 seconds because there's lag yeah
ok 5 plus though is a little too much
yeah was always a bit too much I'm
going for the next against Muhammad see
how I see how is successfully I fixed my
rating to be 2200 just for the stream
okay like no more no less
it's you know it's easy to get over 2200
but 22 exactly that's that's requires a
real skill Oh
again didn't have a chance to play the
events so let's play this petrol oh but
that's which one will you go for that's
the best one
okay I know you like that one so I'm
playing it because yeah and everything
is so fast I'm amazed yeah I got more
RAM and now everything is just really
flying I have to test it because
previously when I tried playing higher
bullet and streaming it always lagged
and my computer lags the stream light
everything back so maybe now it wouldn't
he didn't push c4 yeah I I don't think a
c4 was good I just thought he will play
it
mmm okay let's play it like this he
wants to see the lolly gambit was the
Lola gambit I have no idea that's like a
new thing right I haven't heard loli
gambit holy gambit guys
yeah you can also accept one-minute
challenges it's not a problem yeah well
of course I'm just going in do you know
that's not both of the engine so that
the engine boy is a different dude
but it's interesting with people still
remember those are the engine boy even
though they're joined us only once the
other constantly ask us where is he yeah
and on reddit someone posted a meme
saying you know how it's bad to cheat
with an engine but it's ok to cheat with
dota the engine boy ok you know silent
by the deadly yeah everything should be
mandatory if you can play it you must
play it yes yeah I will but somebody
should give me the opportunity but even
even Michael foul plays only twice in
his career in in real you know classical
chess games he won both the both games
but he probably didn't play it for a
good reason
and once he played against it with the
black pieces also a very nice game yeah
yeah no we're not going to show it well
yes but you know I can show everything
right away of course you have to wait
with these things that's a good piece
yeah I mean anything works here ok
that's a queen
ok and I can simply check it yeah almost
yeah but not gonna happen you have an
ultra bullets challenge where it's not
it's ultra bullet plus one okay it's not
gonna work I do want to how you will
accept it yeah ok yeah why did you want
one no it isn't it stupid so oh I saw
the deal I thought you took the ultra
bullet one no no no that's that's too
much for me ah Kings gambit or a
budapest gambit ok
you like the budapest game budapest is
with d4 and d5
yeah but not immediately okay Knight f6
into n e5 ok say but cannot really play
it here yeah no you can't not now you
can't play anything on light of 3 you
can play g5 immediately
No yeah it's a nice gambit especially if
he doesn't capture it
mm-hmm okay not black his win yeah where
we'll go
I think the capture on f7 that's the
only way to do it okay let's see but I
think you'll go 93 no I'll capture on d4
that's a pond
yeah Owens defense that's nice a
beautiful beautiful stuff look at all
these ponds going killing it
hold my beer is asking are we about to
make a stream and and talk in creation
well I don't see that happening but you
never know
simply because almost none of my
subscribers are from Croatia it's like
0.7% of B of people who watch the
channel are from Croatia so it would be
well it's not a one if you consider that
35% of them are from the United States
okay and well most people in Croatia
speak English but not a lot of people
from the United States speak creation so
this is win-win
guru so gambit oh well here as someone
said that that they love the guy in the
back okay so there you already have a
fan how many from Germany yeah I
actually think Germany is also in the
top top five percentages I think maybe
in I think it's United States then it's
India India is like 11 or 12 percent
then it's a Germany Australia and Canada
I think that's that's not five pretty
sure I will check though I think I even
published it a few weeks ago on Twitter
but maybe it changed a bit how many from
Norway I think Norway is also in the in
the top like 10 you know nah somewhere
around 5%
okay I would like to say but the the
chat is flying a bit too much yeah
asking for every country yeah every Eric
Rosen is in the tournament well I I did
expect him to be in the tournament a lot
of people should join is he and I know
he's not here
I think he's a bit okay okay most likely
he will be streaming also last time yeah
last time everyone on Twitch was
streaming this tournament so you know
the more the merrier I mean no I don't
expect everyone to watch this stream
there are a lot of other streams you
know all right oh that's that's nice
King g7 the best don't want to go there
still don't want to go there don't want
to go there when the brain is thinking
you you know it's a shame the night is
here oh but you can kick it away
yeah with night before such a beautiful
distraction oh I didn't think he will
capture oh he didn't want to allow me
shame okay undoing this cool another two
plus so refused challenge well that's
that's simply not possible Alicia says
it is refused
yeah that's maybe you challenge someone
else who refused it I don't think we've
refused any challenges so long as there
are we are just ignoring some people not
on purpose of course yeah I mean the if
you are putting alike playing those
games unlimited games and like anything
below three plus so and tribulus so no
anything above but yeah I constantly
think that I will mention this to
leeches or at least try to mention it
that there should be some sort of a
queue during
challenges that if you challenge you
enter a queue and then it's accepted
automatically because here it's not
chronological it's not it's just you
know switches because the the order of
the people who challenge it doesn't
remain the same yeah you can never know
whose turn it is for the challenge it's
you know it sometimes seem like someone
is waiting for a long time but it's
really impossible to figure it out
favorite beer style beer or beard
what's a beer style what is this
what am i playing well you are playing
the the yeah that's the only move aside
from Queen b6 if you don't want to lose
a piece I thought you were gonna go King
d8 Oh
maybe yeah that's why it will be 6 and
then king days but still be five why it
should be better what so many people
from Tunis ah the grub oh okay that
cheap for right yeah but you can also go
before immediately that's the Hungarian
polish check oh it's uh this is a really
tough game unless it's not it's okay Tom
yeah okay serious there's so many people
from Tunis
okay we have an Alaska and French am i
sup to the PewDiePie I don't think I am
okay random dudes it seemed planets he
made a mistake
ah bread em Jones let's go for it
other by John feels 5 percent I don't
know I imagine it is somewhere in the in
the top but I don't think it's already
5% have we how old is middle middle is
well we
we don't have him since birth so it's
it's hard to say but he's 12 or 13
somewhere in between Bishop c5 and
before Evans gambit is on the board all
right let's see how you do okay pretty
much the same that yeah it's a move you
just continue in the same fraction no
that's not something you do okay I will
believe because I don't have a clue
about the Evans gambit
I'm guessing d4 yeah should work maybe
it doesn't matter in Evans gambit you
always win
it doesn't matter what your opponent
plays okay that's how young lady ever
knew gambit oh what'd you do what if
your opponent plays against the Evans
gambit you will now Bishop before
no that's king of fun problem okay this
is now winning itself okay you have a
center and your opponent has no
compensation well I would go with the
knight but that's just me hmm okay I
will once again make him make him take
it okay yeah the position plays itself
really I think it's gonna go Knight e4 e
for ya yeah even better or not Oh G for
very nice let's leave this Knight
yeah that's that's the way to do it or
no oh I don't think you'll capture it
but I'll probably go Castle yeah
but then just okay I'm not gonna say
anything but you see it's very very
enjoyable yeah really just playing
itself mighty for what
Maximilian says what do I do for a job I
I draw people with the Evans gambit most
of the days may the bark twice if I
gotta matter is nice too yeah he's too
satisfied because he just had a long
walk and a huge meal so otherwise I'm
pretty sure he would have what's
it just simply destroy this pawn
structure how do you know each other
III think we already discussed that who
I I think they're referring to the two
of us okay yeah Tina and I have been
neighbors for thirty years
yeah so you know we know each other
since since always
and and I've met young in the chest and
in the Chess Club when I decided to join
the Chess Club and then they told me go
play against young it was it was a wild
game I lost in I believe eight moves
well it was a it was a Sicilian and I
played f4 to to your c5 and then he just
ended abraca you went he five I play the
f kappa Queen h4 check and then it's
just lost what you know I never even
played the real game up until then yeah
but it was a very principled very nicely
done he five and then you know as I had
no clue what I was doing was over very
quickly ah do you listen to English
songs do you listen to English songs do
you hear them yes yes you do alright how
about in understand okay let's go for
another game
it's mister Keshava I don't check the
term you have to check the tournament
after every game because it might start
and we might miss it and you are the
tournament the director 26 minutes okay
and we are not at the front page all
right okay still to GM's alright and
just fine
but probably after anymore no it's
excellent but not for the people playing
for me watching the air will be quite
enjoyable but whose wheels have in third
place and an untitled player from
Azerbaijan yeah 20800 untitled player
from Azerbaijan maybe he just started
playing chess well no he plays on
another platform and he just
oh boy you're down to 50 seconds well
that wasn't on purpose
are you are you taking care of not
accepting rated games yes I am of course
Oh night of 695 right well of course
well I also don't know this opening
matter it doesn't matter
oh he went for the Traxler now you were
doomed what you're doing
am I in some oh well you have to know
how to play this I don't know how to
play go Kings you want only move okay
maybe that's a check Madrid or also here
come on yeah it's uh you really he knows
what he's doing
Knight g4 is the point oh okay man yeah
nice it's not all that all that's easy
to play this but you should be winning
yeah really yeah yeah but you already
started with 30 seconds on the clock
or was it 50 I'll just try to play as
fast as I can
yeah maybe they'll capture my rock I'll
capture maybe you can flag him dad that
also might work he's thinking
so that's something's going for me here
yep all right captured rook no he wants
he's gonna go back 94 he's a good player
see it says God thank God
oh no he's gonna capture it okay okay
what might see two very development
development
okay I'll capture that one okay oh dude
okay he missed it and he was so close
guess who I guess Castle Bishop d6 is
coming there's a queen
whoa cannot capture like this for root
before for him oh okay g3 he missed it
that'll be a nice one man is this what
Queen b5 probably gonna try something
like that yeah but okay
it's fine yeah but nicely too but he
played an interesting game yeah but it's
not over
what is Quincy - he's okay Wow
yeah almost a flag and he did flag you
did come on
well I mean that's a pretty pretty fast
Mouse you should really play faster yeah
I really don't know but it doesn't
matter it's a it's a good game by mr.
Kesh off and he deserves to win because
he played the Traxler that's how it just
works
yeah come run okay
oh are you are not afraid to accept him
it's a it's a rating without question
mark he could be 3,000 he he is probably
like mr. Victor says working he get a
t-shirt like this it's it's a
one-of-a-kind well it's actually for our
kind so but if you if you really want it
I mean I I it's I don't really need it
come on
well you will remember this day every
time you put on the shirt so you know
it's a very loud shirt
this isn't print this is okay this is
better than last time but it's really
loud when you walk you know you can
sneak up on people that's - and we all
know how you like you know yeah I do
like that
oh the stream seems to be lagging again
but it's the it's the my service
provider you know it can be avoided so
shouldn't stress out about it a bit too
much as that there's nothing we can do
still still can't control a bit of
weather unfortunately yeah and it's it
just noticed also when I'm playing
because I'm 130 seconds here and I'm
kind of playing yeah you don't sometimes
you don't even see how much time you
have because of the challenges
okay fortunately yeah people people say
people are saying there's lag okay so
the tournament starts in 20 20 minutes
yeah viewers will experience buffering
still no idea why why that would be the
case but you know yeah yeah yeah
apologies to everyone but it will just
have to write it out YouTube's been
having a rough few days and it seems to
be taking at all even even on the live
streaming we'll see we'll see if we can
fix it it does say that YouTube is not
receiving enough video to maintain so
much streaming as such viewers will
experience buffering no no the
resolution of the camera is is fed into
the OBS but the resolution of the OBS is
still the same we just get a wider angle
that doesn't run into it which is better
Dean which I do Dhiru Lopez the rule
opens of course of course everything is
better than English yeah
not the people yeah of course there are
no rule office people there are some
I've shown the game game by by an hour
Lopez but it wasn't really Lopez okay I
think we have the real value cos ah Rio
Lopez real yeah Roy or Rob Rob Robert I
don't think you you can say that three
times fast
yeah it's not not about India there's
lag everywhere since YouTube really does
have a rough few days so lag stopped
okay
I'm very happy if that is the case oh
yeah I forgot to mention to everyone if
you're interested in joining the
tournament that starts in 20 minutes you
can easily join it just click on the
link in the description below this time
there is no password so
what what is happening stuff and yeah
since some of you might also be
interested what what board do I use for
my regular videos it's it's the the
normal wooden board on chess comm I
don't remember the theme I I changed it
like a few years ago and haven't
switched to anything else since then Oh
indeed huh Mike and Mike is going for it
okay at least you have time yeah yeah I
wanted to say something but I forgot
what it was yeah for those of you who
want to join just click on the link in
the description below this time there's
no password anyone can join you can even
join after the tournament starts doesn't
really matter you can play a little bit
of the tournament and then like take a
break maybe you don't have something to
eat and then continue at the tournament
won't mind what you will of course not
be able to win as many points odd some
people say the lag stopped a long time
ago so I was very happy about that well
and mr. Augustine Bernal says that he's
watching in 1 ATP and it looks nice as
well okay so that's good and yet another
person asked where is da da da engine
boy well since you're asking he's
waiting for his wife to give birth to
their baby he's waiting for quite a
while he's waiting for like two weeks
now look at this
runaway king oh that's is there a king
walk or a king March that's the question
that's like I don't know makes little
Mike and bike whoa
it's defended here as well oh come on
man I think he has you know it's a
perpetual yeah but okay I have to go
back yeah you have to go back and then
then does he have a check I don't think
so
he might have a check mate
good where yes like that that's what I
would play I would doesn't work yeah but
now rue capture g7
yeah but King f5 you can get five huh
yeah
tough luck Mike and bike but a good game
yeah good game nice nice King walk okay
let's move on yeah I think loglog
yeah still the lag 17 minutes okay it
says yawn your king is on a four yeah
yeah it's uh none there's nothing to be
done about it I mean there I can't even
voluntarily lower the quality of the
stream or something because it's already
at a very low quality and the stream is
set to run as smoothly as possible so
why is the friend not talking teen check
the it's his first stream and you know
he he's uh getting used to it yeah yeah
here in time
yeah he's not like daughter don't worry
ok mr. ARP I think we'll have to yeah
we'll have to abort that or you can you
can exit the ones that are like today
challenge or so and they're not in the
way yeah we do have a lot of people
challenging a hundred and fifty-five oh
that's the one
don't want to play ultra bullet no did
you want to play it again
maybe no no I'm just later yeah okay
when I have a bit more soda
Johnny item see if it was yeah since
some people say it's lagging other
people say that they are watching in one
ATP it's uh
I don't know our article 13 really might
be kicking in it's uh it's hard to say
positively spot but it's a lot of fans
from there so I've heard and
and thanks for that still haven't
visited but you know it is definitely on
my visit list which is quite large don't
say I haven't been anywhere
okay the the rating didn't drop this is
the Blitz rating 2201 was the bullet
rating so not not to worry I have a
matter that I'm losing his rating yeah
although even this one I believe was
twenty something I lost some of the
games I believe yeah okay I seem to be
that way okay so Johnny item as well
doesn't really respond or is it the
internet connection no no it's reaches
so is working perfectly fine so it ended
the Internet in general so it's it's
completely it you think is the stream on
Twitch no it's not it's only on YouTube
some people do stream simultaneously on
Twitch in YouTube but both YouTube says
that they will ban you if you if you
double stream and also twitch says that
so I I'm still not partnered with twitch
I never get like two weeks I think I
forgot what it was you have to stream
like for two weeks and have 70 viewers
per stream something like that I don't
think it would be a problem to become a
partner but I never gets two weeks where
I can stream every day okay but I am
planning to do it once it seems that
people stopped wanting to play against
me for some reason for some reason yeah
you're too strong maybe okay so still
stream complete ah now its just stream
complete it says uploading yeah it
finally a game AHA okay there so there
is a nice work around or maybe a hack
says rewind a few seconds and it will no
longer lag
yeah I know it's it's not the best
workaround not definitely not a hair
but
whoa
I'm killing myself here what is this
no all right it's the one that that's
the best yeah oh my god okay okay now
you win how we can't do puzzle Russians
that says that come think so no not
gonna be able to do it here okay I think
we're back it's not I still I think the
the video is still in poor health but
there is no way around it and seriously
my internet service provider always has
problems when the weather is bad and
here it's like really terrible weather
for the past few days
so there is no work around a rock around
for that we need to knock we need to so
we're just gonna as we cannot affect it
we're just gonna ignore it but I believe
it is working fine now what even when it
won't be worse though just gonna ignore
it and focus on the positions at hand
yet which takes a lot of bandwidth just
watch that's uh well I don't know it
seemed I don't YouTube seemed better for
me when I was deciding what to do yeah
mr. Farris is persistent for us to do a
puzzle rush yeah okay some of the we
have a puzzle rushman yeah
do do I answer Facebook messages I do
not all of them but I do as much as I
can
Edward Snowden is hacking the stream so
unpolite of him hmm it's an interesting
situation the king is in the center and
you have two undeveloped rooks yeah and
a very bad night yeah it's not a bad
night it's a good night you forced his
queen back should be should be nice
response to that as well yeah I think
[Music]
yeah yeah it's a nice game hmm yeah I
have a good good idea but you know I'd
be unfair for me to say it out loud okay
then don't say yeah and just tell me
what you thought after I play okay see
it seems fair
yeah I mean obviously you can shift it
to 360p but that's no way for for anyone
to live I mean they're just cruel
do you accept our chess960 challenge
yeah why not yeah you know I enjoy that
although there are never any chess960
tournaments did like a chess960 bullet
or something like that there are very
rare you are really really struggling
with this one huh yeah yeah it's a tough
opponent and he there are only now he
captures the night that's the way to
play yes you're hoping he captures with
the bishop but he's not going to yeah
having a strong night in the center
you're gonna capture it no but okay
still playing the game okay let me just
refill my soda soda
yep that's coke yeah no it's not only
nine minutes from the tournament okay
yeah gonna pay more attention to death
but I still think you have time for one
more yeah ah mr. nail Barker says that
he's 23rd hundred out of the 2400 before
the tournament starts he's hoping that
he can keep that I hope as well it's
time to go all in Bend fine gold versus
other matter I don't think so I I saw
what he did to Simon Williams you know
I'm not that'd be a slaughter unless it
was like a charity event then then it'd
be okay oh I don't mind losing to food
for a good cause but also just for fun
yeah 144 P game
okay well it seems that thanks it is
possible for you to win on time is it
it seems to be the case so I will
probably get checkmated some Oh who's
the Queen yeah but no he is down to
three seconds you can do it what now
Oh a nice check you're gonna block the
captured he hit have excellent
compensation yeah but you know no no
that's a saving game yeah what do you
have you have King Godfrey you have 2400
people 2472 and let's see 1996 in first
place never enough in second kebab asada
in third dark goo international mastered
our food and feed a master austin 23
then fidel master matthew g p for feet
then in an international master money
romania then candidate master elm 2007
then i am alexander one of and feeder
master magic candy who is just a fierce
bullet player i think i have like a 1/2
to 13 and a half against him yeah yeah
we can show yeah yes yeah half the
fourteen and a half it doesn't matter
how fast i play he always out quickens
me and out with me okay so six minutes
to go let's play a bullet game maybe
then another bullet game that would be
yeah i think so
and the photos oh yeah I forgot to say
for those of you wondering when are the
giveaway is happening it will be after
the tournament not immediately after
after the tournament we're gonna be
accepting some challenges
maybe I play a few games the new class
few games then Tino plays a few games if
you know you'll be interested and only
then do we do the giveaway which will be
still haven't decided but it will be
something like 9 9 mg
cards plus one a larger one as the first
prize for the giveaway as it's much
better than than a championship chested
that we had like in the previous stream
for two hundred thousand subscribers
since it's much easier to ship a gift
card and it's much better since no no
shipping fee you will just order a chest
that if you if you enjoy press it or you
can get some books or like I said I
bobby fisher' action figure and and
stuff like that everybody's betting on
that action figure
yeah yeah I actually had an offer for
someone to make it he makes little
figurines and he said that you can make
a Bobby Fischer action figure
but when he created the head and he
asked me if this was all right you know
should he continue it wasn't a really
good head okay yeah it it didn't look
like Bobby Fischer at all yeah I mean
it's it was a bad head it was a nice
head but it just if you ask someone is
this bobby fischer they would say no for
if you ask them who is this
they put I probably wouldn't know Jews
says post-rock from Croatia
thanks man the video is end no the video
is not end hopefully but you're around
to ten seconds but my game is at an end
okay offer a draw I'm kidding I'm
kidding
people lose a pawn no you know you want
seriously we're gonna go into an NPM no
much time yeah
with so much time I don't think you
realized that he was the town I so much
I'm such a bad bullet player but let's
find another bullet yeah what is your
favorite beverage or snack of course the
one I'm drinking right now ah the but
you can you can of course guess what it
is
yes and for snack Oh again someone says
the video stopped okay
YouTube has some serious problems to
deal with
I'm playing this opening for the second
time nobody wants to accept the budapest
gambit and what is your favorite whiskey
[Laughter]
okay yeah without any alcohol would you
say beer is an acquired taste or or is
beer just you know beer I don't know I
mean did you enjoy beer since forever I
think I did yeah I would say that too
but it's hard to say some people don't
like it yeah of course some people I
know that people prefer wine but I don't
think that they necessarily don't like
beer yeah because when you're younger
you can't really afford good wine and
you can always afford beer yeah so
there's that thank you mister dude thank
you for for your congratulations Robbie
seven and how do you play from here you
can walk was only five twenty five he
was for the easy way out oh nice mr.
Jones with the moose rook captures oh he
played Queen captures Wow okay he wants
to keep me suffering and I don't know
what to play yeah if you have a terrible
position
you should play fast that's true
okay that's amazing one but you know
it's time for people to play Alexi okay
the tournament is starting in in a
minute and we'll see okay so no
surprises for now pretty much everyone
on the first page is titled can you
check the second page yes mr. tournament
director well of course of course
okay we have a lot of people Eric Rosen
still in top 20 dota is life okay
the word is that I remember that player
in dota is like 14th
ah okay but you didn't play against him
nope no I we have a person who is
streaming in 13th place okay cook crunch
on United States not sure who that is
but we will find out definitely okay
mister mister mister serum guru says why
did the an almighty stop his chest
channel he is enjoying life too much to
do videos actually just to apply I can't
expect that question but I didn't really
stop it it's kind of kind of a long
vacation but although it will be
explained in my next video which will
come soon maybe even this week yeah keep
you posted about that yeah I just
received the eight seven three two why
I'm that one zero that one yeah yeah
that's why we're having oh okay you can
play that one oh yeah I forgot it did
you join the turtle yeah I accidentally
but you can OS serrated okay okay let me
play then yeah I I'm not playing in this
tournament and I kept your writing man
no all right I don't wanna I mean so I
wasn't hoping to play it at all
I was hoping to comment on and I will I
will remove myself from the tournament
after this game I just joined just to
keep the number a little bit higher
yeah you know one more one more
okay have to definitely get this Bishop
away from there he's gonna go oh no I
have to move that but I thought you will
capture it but this night md5 is amazing
yeah it is
I just have to get my rook in their
games yeah now okay now oh it's okay
let's go here
right off everything so he has a better
position of course but there's nothing
to be worried about
I can just go capture here I don't mind
I'm just gonna push okay oh it's a two
minutes yeah I thought it was a bullet
but okay I do seem to be playing a bit
too fast for the occasion
yeah that's that's no good yeah enters
the king that's no good okay not too
interested in that let's go I have to
push it's the only thing I have okay
five but that's not it
okay still hoping to to bust open and
maybe only slightly lose this okay more
time I know because I thought I was
playing bullet but I'm not
and now if it was okay that's a nice
move what's the threat yes ah look here
okay but I just move and yeah okay nice
I mean it's the game okay let's just can
we do at least anything nope still not
able to do anything okay so just a
terrible position for me yeah that's a
resigned material okay yeah okay fair
enough resign and pause okay I've been
back to the tournament yeah okay whoo
good game yeah you play one game and
this guy already played three yeah ah he
is probably berserk King it's probably a
very strong player that berserks but if
he would be breaking he'll have three
points more but okay uh what happened
with the YouTube match and Twitter they
blundered apiece and then
I tried to make a different move but
they just couldn't recreate the position
they had problems with it but I will ask
them what happens you should have opened
it in another tab okay I will have to be
immediately sorry okay but we do have
over 3,000 players and evolve a chess or
Canada mestrovic chess is always in the
top ten whenever there's a stream so
yeah I think is uh you know he's
currently playing and he's from Russia
so a candidate's master from Russia
that's like a GM is here in Croatia yeah
okay so now we are going to so the idea
of this whole thing is going to be that
we are going to look at some games try
to comment a little bit yeah just have
fun and enjoy them yeah because it's
possible yeah yeah it's yeah but it's
always enjoyable when you have so many
people fighting for the top place it's
just nice to watch when you don't have
to do all the struggling yeah sometimes
it's better to just sit back yeah even
though we all could play chess for hours
and hours and it wouldn't be really a
struggle but still it's nice you can
check out all the ideas you can have
some ideas like c4 is a threat now so he
runs away and you know going for the
exchange whoa what's that c4 seems
excellent yeah Bishop c4 no Bishop c4
yeah but he saves the rook yeah c4 was
better but yeah you don't lose the rook
yeah that's why we comment on games we
give the other perspective GM Knight
Genghis Carlsen no it's not oh look at
that
wow that's some amazing but oh but that
just loses too hard
very nice wow that was so good
yeah and this is only the second game
we're watching or the first yeah the
first one was was mine yeah no I really
thought I was having a nice position
because I thought it was a bullet but
then when I saw it was 2 minutes
I was like yeah ok so what how will
white exploit the the bishop on f6 yeah
check King g7 doesn't really work
yeah he's gonna push and now Knight f6
check fold by 97 yams possible yeah in
the spirit of Michael tile definitely 95
action Knight of 6 95 but black has a
pawn two points for ya now 97 isn't all
that impressive since it doesn't pin
anything okay black if black wins this
with that rookie three move King g8 and
that's that's super impressive like wow
and what now yeah that's it for now
we're playing for time I guess yeah and
what chess is down
did anyone berserk no really thought a
lot of people will be buzzer King okay
that's why I didn't set it for let's go
for one minute but rather oh and King
crusher also playing oh and streaming of
course that's to be expected
how many streamers do we have six oh I
don't know I don't know if it's six or
more than six and leaches is only able
to throw six but okay okay I'm sure
someone will inform me in the chat let's
check out the best okay a lot of players
already a player here
oh I've played so many games against him
he's very strong
okay I think it's the 23
okay okay but it's not bad I mean I did
win six yeah that's actually against a
guy with 2,500 yes I think the the ones
I want were hyper bullet and water all
the other ones that he won were bullet
okay he's having kind of a strong attack
here on the Queen's
yeah okay that's unexpected if I'm gonna
go for trapping the bishops for a five
but it's always better to push the
double bond immediately King goes ah and
mr. Steven how do you pronounce this
cube cube is it - it is the soft yeah
chip could be but yeah he did berserk so
yeah he says it doesn't matter you have
a higher rating than me I'm a title
player so I can preserve that's that's
what he's saying here c4 right ah for
white or black for black yes for life
yes but it's maybe one of the most it
only looks good he wants to go Ruby yeah
now it's the one characters and okay
I don't know yeah not I mean you you're
not going anywhere
yeah just evil before yeah but he can
undermine it so it's not a problem okay
probably a draw is going to he can
undermine yeah it's a draw and uh he
accepted it wasn't a repeating of the
position Wow okay let's let some true
sportsmanship yeah we're already here
and we do have a little bit of a change
in the first streaking crusher came to
the third place yes Burger King every
game so as usual we have to be very
careful about the gentleman with with no
reading as you know let's check out this
game yeah sure I don't think anyone is
cheating but every game we every
tournament we have there there's a
cheater so yeah we don't wanna accuse
him yeah and of course not accusing
anyone but it's just fact okay he
already has a pond which you want on
these six playing against 2600 yeah okay
that's a bishop playing quite fast as
well
yeah but the candidate master berserk so
we'll see and it does seem to be
everything seems to be all in order with
the stream I think just why does every
surname in Croatia finish finishes with
each it doesn't he actually does many of
them do but yeah I don't think even most
of them do yeah they do yeah they do
I think so does your surname I don't
like isn't like the most we're two for
one here like the most creation name is
like tomislav Horvath or something like
that yeah Horowitz is like one of the
most common yeah and it doesn't have a
niche and you know okay but if you look
at the top ten I think that domain of
what so top ten most common surnames in
Croatia and welcome are in each yeah
okay I don't know I mean I presume it is
like that like even charge or something
that's like also one of the most common
names and surnames that's like really
annoying when I when I google even chart
each I'm interested in the even strategy
to plays chess and then I get to the
comedian the basketball player the
tennis player the golf player even shots
and please come on you know me I'm
interested in the guy that plays chess
yeah and it is always just problem
you're not truck tracking me yeah like
and then they're always tracking me when
I don't want them but now when I really
wanna something like you know we're
totally not sure what you're looking for
yeah it's like you're destined to play
some sports if you're yes yes especially
but okay it seems like the the candidate
master here managed to overcome the
challenge even though he berserk Kong
has a rope but it's ten seconds yeah I
don't think he minds he's just gonna
pull it up
he's gonna find ok he didn't grab it I
thought yeah but I grabbed it oh oh he's
gonna go for a quick man yeah very nice
that's how we do it
ok now he managed to kick good point
yeah so okay but we've eliminated the
possibility of mr. yl h 16 being a
cheater at least okay that's but still
there's dirty gangsta you know yeah
let's check out the dirty gangsta he's
playing against feeding master yes
yeah but dirty gangster has 2500 yeah
yeah so so let's see how dirty he really
is yeah he played English so is that
yeah Bogdan Allah which is a creation
gym that's true
twitter is down twitter is not down
twitter is never down actually a while
ago Facebook and instrument-board up
right yeah I'm not surprised by that but
it seems like everything is down lately
play the bone cloud okay we should look
for someone who plays the bone cloud
okay that's all so you'll have to remind
me what that is that's also I just you
know a freaking if - okay I circle with
the King and oh you know you humiliate
your opponent and then claim you're the
best
yeah the best in the worst opening yeah
but it'll be interesting if lishus had
had an option where you could there are
4000 people or something playing the
tournament now if you could search bong
cloud and then it shows you all the
games where bone called is going to
being played that would be nice or the
Evans gambit you know yeah that's like a
new feature request that would maybe
yeah I mean a lot of people watching a
lot of people playing if everyone joins
together I'm sure there'd be a lot of
good ideas not like this one but better
but seriously it's a it could so it it's
not like we only have to do it for this
particular tournament if you are
sometimes from the way
and you decide you wanna see a game
played in and it were an offense yet for
it it would also improve the quality of
streamers because you could just fire up
your stream and say okay now we're gonna
search for any game where the Berlin is
being played and I will explain it for
example not me I'm not really good at
explaining but someone oh there goes and
dirty gangstas so dirty night of six
sneaky very nice we didn't expect any
here okay dirty Gangstar very impressive
but I can go you see after I see the
game I can simply go to the tournament
okay so I will still open it in another
tab who is candidate master bonel
Levitch vanilla which is from South
Africa and you played against him oh
yeah I have Wow okay nice every game
with all victories and do how many
people are with all victories so far so
dirty gangsta okay he drew the first
game yeah so Rack Attack
in the second place also hot deal okay
fourth place
Helen 1993 ok cabbage nine cabbage I
want to see a game from cabbage yeah he
probably goes for the cabbage attack
let's see he's playing again just know
may be really cool if he played the
cabbage deck very strong game oh it's a
French he's playing against Grandmaster
very cold okay we didn't see him at the
beginning no he may be just joined and I
don't know who that is see the countries
Argentina but not anything else
and he only plays bullets and wrap it
that's what I respect no no blitz blitz
but that's blitz wrap it is alright yeah
sorry I meant blitz no no one please
wrap it
whoa okay already we have what this oh
what an interesting position can mr.
cabbage survive this
I don't know this is too much oh oh the
door is the fencing and the best regards
e6
okay he finds it he finds the poison and
the meanest larceny for the Queen at
7:00 and then the night is week cap yeah
captures guards the one on h4 and now h5
okay but first black pushes as well whoa
black and your family well six nice oh
what's that
Queen geez yeah I know that's nice but
Bishop e6 but then porn yeah
Oh going for the perpetual I don't think
he's going for the perpetual he will
dissipate he was play for the win here
he has to play Bishop taste extent but
should be too
whoa okay that's the stuff but Queen d24
yeah that's what Bishop first the move
with the bishop yeah but 97 yeah I know
yeah there it's not all that Queen what
but nevertheless very still he's gonna
maybe mr. page sick Oh
rook blocks okay Queen is under attack
Queen eight sacks and not Bishop to b2
yeah well black is so good here black is
playing very nicely also white is
attacking very nicely yeah but that you
know refute such an attack from a
grandmaster very impressive
okay Queen g6 okay okay I am really
really impressed by mr. cabbage Queen c6
and that's you know when someone has a
nickname cabbage yeah and plays like
this that's very impressive
yeah wow captures captures whoa okay
that was very clean oh yeah super guard
e5 oh my all right the Grandmaster shows
what it means to be a grandmaster very
nice GM nineteen who beat him the first
game was the probably played against
another GM because you can just click a
left-click on him and any table it will
show you know left click yeah okay GM
never enough yeah he was against GM
never enough okay let's check out this
game
whose night king oh there we have it
tonight King versus oh and both berserk
very nice let's see let's see
okay what about nineteen you're going
for it
Queen jutsu yeah nope that's it yeah
there's no okay brother King all the
games and it seems it's working her yeah
but well didn't face dirty gangsta okay
do I enjoy the Owens defense yes I do
it's a very nice defense let's check out
another game by the night King because
this one was quite short and and we have
international master Zuber it could be a
pirate
the nice thing is he likes to fianchetto
his bishops it seems yeah who doesn't
okay you are all geeks thank you well
dia thank you sir I also thought that
was it coach yeah meteor what do we have
here what about a giveaway
another question aha a picture we
already mentioned the win the giveaway
the giveaway is after the tournament but
not immediately after like there's the
tournament will okay the stream was for
an hour then we have a tournament for
two hours then we're gonna accept some
challenges for like half an hour and
then we do the giveaway and then that's
that's about it pretty much it yeah it
has to be shorter than four hours as
YouTube only records the first four
hours of the stream but the stream did
break down a few times so I don't know
if it still counts as as four hours yeah
because for example oh no it's fine
right what one hour and 17 minutes and
we started is precisely so YouTube will
immediately connect the dots I like that
very nice at least there wrote some code
correctly yeah okay going for that d5
ooh the Queen lf5 running away hmm but
now
well capture probably rook beat upon and
the H upon so now not to fumble
yeah he can't go for the c7 square
because of the night
that's exactly everything like I would
have played it yeah only only for I mean
floor yeah no I mean you wouldn't you
would play it faster okay
still a pawn for white now with stronger
bishops when Bishop comes from these six
that the time is equal it's a really
tough game oh and the nice King make use
of it
there goes the h3 pawn but still okay
it's time to check and ninety-six
okay no I thought Knight b6 and then
check by yeah you you can never whoa and
now will the rook fall okay why not grab
that one I don't know what's happening
this is crazy
check check and game what check oh he's
getting made it
no he's not wow this is some great
maneuvering check ok they're satisfied
with the draw I guess yeah flag him whoa
that's simply more time night King Flags
Zuber the night King stays in the lead
with 12 points ahead against and third
against the lost
- who - Federico - Salma no the
feathering no - sana out Salma Oh with
Sanne and where is Sola so is aha mmm
nowhere to be found well maybe on the
second page how probably it was Oh
checkmate what
very nice to check me look oh they like
I want to capture oh and I also want to
check me to you at the same time okay
that's a nice position okay we do have a
raccattack when he drew the first game
you Rachel it okay let's go back to Rack
Attack okay I have eleven eight against
him so it's then he seems to be very
strong okay so two GM's in the lead
butlet's
animal let's check out a game again but
where's the third gene the the nowhere
mister nowhere he left I don't know
first range okay let's see Aleksandra
Lanos okay okay yeah what I wanted to
miss a game from the two genes but in
the end yeah and it's also night king
berserk so very nice and so far you
think out of the seven games they've
played it seemed only one draw for a
loan of yeah Thank You mr. rockin
Villanova please check out the CM okay
regarding that one very nice can he do
it
well he's not better and I thought that
the rock should be in front of me phone
yeah but he's trying to do something
black has an easy in here have six
probably oh I know okay
yeah but Lana will surely try to flag
him yeah as you do but looky but will he
lose because he's trying to flag has to
choose wrong no I think you'll accept a
draw he said no he's
now he's gonna push push a 4 and F 3 and
then like winds
she's freaking him yes he was waiting
for that cantilever 3 yeah he's trying
to flag him but I don't know I hope it
doesn't work against him in the end
yeah but it can't okay now it's done
okay now he look like him yeah yeah he
will not
yeah okay it's impossible to flag okay
wow that's a that's a fighting draw
that's a flag that's a hundred 116 moves
for a really bullet yeah even though I
I've seen some people call 2 minutes 2
plus 0 hypo bullet hypo yeah like ok I
think it's a good idea because it's not
blitz and it's not really bullet so
hyperbole it seems appropriate okay
I never in mister never enough is back
at 47th place okay and he starts berserk
in to catch up but it doesn't go his way
and King crusher also doesn't seem to be
young a lot of luck with with berserk
King but he always berserk so he doesn't
mind
yeah you just enjoying the game yeah
okay let's go back to the first page and
let's check out another title player
that we haven't seen yet miss Abigail D
mr. Bubba guilty what am i hearing
double moves I'm not I thought I was
okay yes Raja is he's quite the player
he won the previous tournament and it
previous title arena no no the 200000
subscribers not the first place but the
second place penguin one first okay
and I told you that I had to send the
price over to Iran and then I couldn't
send it over PayPal and then I had to go
to the bank and they were like wires and
money to Iran like I'm you know funding
some sort of an organization that I guys
really yeah interesting question yeah
and then I had to sign something and you
know do some paperwork really really
really awful that's just I don't know it
sounds wrong yeah it does
Hey thank you thank you mister kochak
okay so we have white going key
queenside castle with busted bones ah
yeah the pawns that already went into
the attack mr. Baba guilty very
unorthodox a pro what do you think the
two two seven seven is is somehow I
don't think Baba guilty was taken
it's probably the year he will die what
maybe that's my ego he had when he
joined yeah that's that's the first
things FM so 2300 for an FM is needed
right 2323 yeah yeah 2254 for an enemy
and and 23 for an FM and and the war
does it take to get an LM delete
Chessmaster yeah 2100 I don't know or I
think it's 24 in all disciplines or not
no I don't think it is it they just
really they just give it to some people
who they think deserve it like have some
immortals I don't know how it works
yeah probably check it out maybe I could
try it out at least to get some title
jessica says why do you have super chat
and joining turned off
I don't but that feature is not yet
available in Croatia yeah you know we do
have a lovely seaside but we don't have
super chat that's how it works here
[Music]
[Laughter]
what kind of beer are you drinking it's
not beer it's it's soda yeah that's -
apple juice in here yes it's barley soda
barley soda yeah so don't mistake us for
some couple of drunk yeah this player
Debbie Debbie only only somewhat true
yeah in some situations yeah we have
here Thank You mr. ashesh Prasad it's
kind of a draw rockin game ah yeah but
Oh Dave / artem has 14 seconds and down
a pawn so I I think he's lost yes white
will win I mean if he pushes the pawn
the guy just goes Oh sneaky okay
maintain the opposition he 600 do it he
couldn't do it very good job what yeah
it's the correct correct way
nice very nice bye bye Gilda okay but
you can't win all of them yeah but still
it's still too early to tell even
anything it's only half an hour into the
tournament and it's a two hour
tournament so yeah really really too
early to save another draw yet
yeah I think I never even had a draw
against him okay now both of them did
berserk and they usually berserk
they're quite serious about this game oh
yeah but there should be like an option
berserk if your opponent buzzers like
you click in that and then your opponent
gets a duo so maybe one of our circ like
one doesn't want to do it if the other
one doesn't but wait the wind
that the night king is who is right yes
I've heard his brand but you know there
are other theories as well
Federico no no we just know a
grandmaster from Argentina okay let's
check out that Dino is requesting an
Eric Rosen game all right we will surely
check out yeah I have you seen where
when he defeated Carson and he didn't
know he was playing against Carson
though yeah he he played against him in
the first round of the arena of the
title arena he won and then I think it
was one where Carson was playing out of
a van but other when van yeah really
yeah and it's very nice you know yeah
it's not every day you world champion
yeah and it's not every day the world
champion plays out of a van yeah okay
the night king is really going at it
here yeah and that's a nice pawn it's a
four okay include the night into the
game and it all is well I think and he
now trades Wow very simple very simple
and strong just what you would expect
from a grandmaster
no okay mister bullet expert says
Perugia is stronger than Andrew tank
well I don't doubt that he's stronger in
over the board chess in a bullet I've
seen ferocious I like really playing
nice against Nakamura
so probably would be a nice nice match
to watch
well night d5 on h3 is in trouble what
do I plan when I retire when I retire
well then I'm finally gonna play some
chess like you don't really just enjoy
so not not much different than what I do
now
never retire yeah
thank you mr. Mike Mike tharid Mr Hall's
Germany there are we this time we we
said we were gonna only do soda so yeah
we cannot drink every time
17 seconds only mm-hmm
I don't know is an exchange down but he
has a pawn here I think more juice than
Federico that's for sure
okay Oh give the night as well but he
doesn't hoping for some checks okay well
like I said it's still early but if we
don't get a really a wild player in I
think it's safe to say that night king
is having you pretty good chances this
tournament yeah that's true yeah but if
you never know you know you might have a
bad internet service provider like me
yeah and you can see if Rosen is
anywhere near the top okay so here I
didn't see him he is an international
master yes yes he is you can also search
okay all right I will type it in I think
he left or it's a no I Derek try Eric
first yeah eyes there okay so here where
is he
okay 93 and Burger King if he's if he's
in the game no just finished okay ah
okay let's see no yeah yeah he just lost
just lost against Yosef yeah okay now
okay
can I really really weird take so long
to get a game Keys amenities for a movie
L maybe who MOV seems like his real name
yep could be worse someone just has a
like like a Bosnian alias yeah that's
totally Bosnian are we right yes we are
you know it could be anything but you
know I took a wild shot
okay what do we have let's see what Eric
has he has a nice dark square bishop
that's true and black we'll try to
counter it probably with Bishop d6 at
some point maybe Oh III know maybe but
huh okay there we have it this should be
60s on the board
oh okay that's greedy that's a healthy
point hmm okay Queen captures rook no no
way to go about it differently and c3
and just you know take it slow
what is it though and now
yeah now c3 okay they're gone why oh my
Eric Rosen one man what's with that
yeah that's unfortunately not a good
thing for it
okay black will still have to work for
his meal but at least now but I would
have actually played queen of two in
this position but okay ah do I think the
drunken stand is in this tournament I
somehow I doubt it I think he just he he
no one the gosh immemorial and he
probably is taking you know a week off
before Greinke chess classic yeah
doesn't have to play yeah I actually
think he plays bullets when he's you
know relaxing you know leeches doesn't
have to be like maybe anywhere yeah
maybe it's um yeah I know he exercises a
lot but for fun I don't know what he
does he plays football right yeah yeah
but that's part of the exercise I
believe part Oh
unless he also plays it for fun how tall
are you a question I am a hundred and
ninety one in centimeters the last time
I checked say yeah last time I checked
yeah Magnus does drink beer that's I
mean everyone brings beer which beer
does it drink I don't know probably some
Norwegian beer yeah some Viking Heil
yeah whoa who do we have here made of
the beast this year but because of this
thing don't see him yeah but it's okay
it's okay he's always in the video yeah
but he's alone he's a greedy little
bastard because we just had a nice big
walk before the stream and now he's
asking for another one but that's just
greedy I mean we went for a big walk
like an hour and a half ago and if he
wants more he wants to be in the
industry okay we're gonna we're gonna
take a break well not you but me because
he's really greedy but then we're gonna
continue but not right away okay we're
gonna go for a walk maybe in what's now
it's 7:40 in 20 minutes cool is that quo
area city just got checked minutes wow
he got checkmated yeah yeah okay this is
not Eric's day but it's still early
yeah so I think it will improve for the
first two places ah no it's still too
early to tell no no way to actually uh
ten minutes ago I was checking out
around the 50th place and I said well
what chest not really having his day as
you can see oh yeah then he started
playing once again so let's check him he
chooses well who he berserks against as
you can see he doesn't deserve just
anyone yeah that's true yeah I told you
every time we have a tournament he's
always in the top ten
let's check out his game not to just see
games Vova chess all right
and they're pretty much equal no not in
this game but in the previous games four
wins for Vova and three for Matthew
the singer nice what if Magnus joins now
well I really think he would win we
would check out some of it yes with
maybe two or three ok Filipina is in the
tournament yeah nice
ok we're gonna we're gonna check out one
game by Filipino hopefully it will be a
nice one
greetings greetings shining light
shining line for Yan what title is cm ya
can't even master I think all the titles
are the same name is English as in
creation I mean the letters in the
titles except the GM of course yeah we
have to have to be different somewhere
yeah although III think it'd be fair if
it was like universal I mean ok
feel the titles are but this message is
helpful review and for good reason sir
hmm ok Matthew is going at it with the
pawns f4 seems to be a dangerous move
mr. Prakash says how do you pronounce a
god matter I pronounce it a good matter
that's how I do it but it's not I mean
you don't have to do it like that it's
like I think like a month ago I
mentioned in a video that the guy who
invented the jiff the moving image he
says that it's actually a jiff not a gif
but everybody says the world doesn't
care you know he's like but I invented
it I choose a what we call it and
they're like no no you don't that's why
you know it's pronounced target matter
but you know I can't force you to prance
it that way alright
what's a child - sorry guys it seems
that maybe we brought you some bad luck
yeah maybe he heard that he was being
given the spotlight and then he tried
playing in there's the pressure of the
stream yeah okay
mr. Kidd Kidd offense no okay one loss
yeah I thought it was without loss let's
check out let's check it out
get offense versus PD sloth well if I
have to choose a nickname it'd be speedy
sloth that's that's a different kind of
sloth yeah not one you see every day
and quite quite a creative name get
offenses in some sort of the trouble
currently not aged five years all right
weekend then oh man he goes back to age
five
okay that's seven after we did for age
five first yeah okay capture capture
Queen hmm yeah yeah I thought he was
gonna go before all this just king of
two and then bring the recover to the
h-file seems a bit weird this trip oh
you had to do it not one is coming queen
is coming nice yeah but can he do it
I mean speedy sloth has 45 key defense
has five okay that's us that's a really
speedy sloth yeah and he's not in the
top ten but and what's also we have
petia came see and have a crocodile okay
we there is no one without loss even
Alexandra one of lost the first game he
played yeah night King and all Thunder
one of dark goo also streaming Sian
peering heart also streaming okay okay I
mean you're the tournament director you
can choose any game okay since a lot of
people have joined the chat if you want
to still join the tournament you can
just click on the link in the
description below just join it's gonna
be you know great and we just saw
nothing losing against getting a shake
mated
and we miss the game oh man okay that
was close
but where is Matthew Oh in fifth place
and he's on a really nice streak let's
then check out his game whoa okay
the regos okay now he defeated the night
king I think he will be unstoppable now
he will just win all the games that's
the confidence you need for this
tournament yup
and even captures on c4 yeah that's
that's how you play much more developed
here white let's see what this mm-hmm
captured if I would repeat nobody won no
no that's a move okay that's a check
yeah that's how you play captures
captures now no I have to think of the
night okay
it's a nice night you don't want to move
it Knight g5 is coming alright c5 nice
c5 okay it's a nice Bishop hmm okay c4
okay now can you go in ig5 and push
maybe e6
if possible maybe yeah but I would
prefer yeah maybe not no with ex9 c5
because of the pin yeah but the idea of
capturing on b7 and Bishop c6 or he's
gonna go yeah just that maybe he had to
do that roof to be one yeah and then
this diagonal would be weak without the
best friend e5 okay coming to c4 okay
which and what now a4 he doesn't want to
trade the white square bishops yeah
now oh nice h4 everything is coming yeah
I just pulled the pole yeah it's not
important now g5 that's insane okay nice
check see he still doesn't want to
capture it he says I will choose when I
capture
that's that's how a champion plays yeah
age five nine of six seems nice
yeah nobody goes for a poem and in such
a situation but he says okay I will not
trade and put my a pawn that's that's
what he wants to do okay wow those are
some nasty pawns huh
that's annoyed okay we saw that check
Wow
what we're now grab the pawn ah the 97
was nice it was but there's time for
that he wants to deliver checkmate
there's no thing well there's a page six
is a game
Matthew very nice nice nicely done very
good
Wow I think he's deserves to be shown on
it from Finland from Finland very nice
they know that Finland has such good
players play against the fishing pole
yeah let's chicken this one out and then
we will go back to the nineteen oh yeah
I mean he does have a winning streak of
like 10 or 12 games impressive we want
to see this is almost as good as your
impressive videos amazing videos yeah I
think it's better fishing pole is going
for the attack with the h4 h5 yeah and
black has a position that always you
know it looks very strong but I I'm
never able to play positions like these
he'll capture on a4 will be attacked no
he was he's gonna push a5 okay
nope he doesn't want to give up a night
before white has to give up some
material here somehow have to move the
night
Go Go f4 something hmm
quickly the capture on f6 month 95
and now okay now he yeah I thought he
might go for that okay
oh good there yeah made me to eat some
grass okay now who's faster here mister
fishing pole is very very low g6 but
okay for really little finding some nice
moves
no 324 I thought what was the point of
this yeah here's a piece up so he
doesn't care okay I actually didn't see
he was a piece up
who is the guy next to Oh God which one
there are two of us yeah although you
are next to me he is behind us although
I will I will probably have to take
metaphor a short walk so not not a long
one he already had a long one he doesn't
want to leave us in charge for too long
yeah yeah might start looking as fringe
defense games okay Matthew one another
one yeah he's really on a roll but ok
let's we didn't see by a game by a
little Plotkin and I know that we yeah
we last tournament he really played some
very impressive games he's up against
magic Andy and we know that you knew of
magic and a plane against Plotkin I
don't know trouble oh very nice very
nice see and is so fast he doesn't care
how much time he has on the clock Oh sir
oh that's the past pawn yeah you will
not be flagging mr. Andy you know yeah
one second for a nice mate nice yeah
that's how Andy rolls okay let's see
another game by mr. magic and two more
players in the top ten without a title
okay we have okay let's check him and
then see if Filipino soup okay we have
to check up on how he's doing
is it is it already 5,000 players
haven't haven't seen 488 four eight nine
okay pretty much we will realize our
market will be yeah somewhere around
that then it you know it's a good
tournament if 5,000 people are playing
it I know that I ask you this every time
but what was the last time the number of
people that participate do you remember
I don't but I think it was around 5,000
maybe 450 or something maybe more I
don't know but doesn't matter if you you
know yeah okay the there are more
subscribers on channel now but no you
know not everyone can join at this
particular time especially you know have
two hours from their time to get to play
it to play chess so all of them playing
leeches yeah okay that's some nasty
messy stuff from magic from Luther
elixir I don't know who that is
international master elixir it's
probably Alex or something
lady 3 Alex do I know uh no I don't okay
it's a nice spawn okay black is going
for the attack okay that's a very
annoying night there he says he doesn't
want to win the bishop on d7 okay why
doesn't he want to win the bishop
discovered check win the bishop there's
some danger here or okay no if he does
it yeah that's the reason it's not a
clear win yeah hmm equal amount of
points really Wow that is not know
before that that's impressive
yeah that Marco to daughter says it well
that's an excellent annoying night
there's the anointed Knight and the
annoying night
asphalt Philippines says how old was I
when I got into chess around I don't
know when was the time I came to the
Chess Club I was like 18
yeah okay let's see magic Andy is still
grinding at it but rather play white
here but it's a draw no it's not in
booth that's not a draw
although a lot of positions are drawn
which I never think there will be no
it's just a nice no it's not that dark
square bishop is looking very good yeah
gonna tag the C pawn but no that's it
that's X Roxy 6mm with d6 c5 d 6f I know
what wow that's nice okay okay not
allowing it but Ruby six no now the
other point comes it's that's over I
mean pawns are pawns
yeah just put the pawn oh nice he got
tricked
yeah okay okay Filipino let's search for
him yeah check out a game for him last
one is always stronger than a piece in
bullet yeah I think that was him yeah is
he playing he was him against Knight
King ah yes he's playing okay you got it
alright guys let's see how he does it's
uh he's winning this one he is ah he's
black yeah Wow
so he was white whoa almost
defend at least one pole okay okay now
you walk it you have to use the king man
somebody needs to take this exposed use
the king okay what no that's
Wow okay but with one second on the
clock
Wow draw no you want no it's a draw it's
a draw ah but the pole was there I think
maybe it would be no it's no yeah I know
if if it's time out then okay that no no
game did we lose him
okay we're chicken yeah yeah so check
out the game another game okay
no not Phileas sorry dude okay okay
there we go yeah I think there was an
option for you to follow the games all
the games but oh if you click on watch
right yeah I think so I think that's how
it works
the guy behind please say something for
the for the for the people yeah it's
it's too far away for for him to to to
comment on the positions and he's only
been playing chess for one week at most
yeah and but he did saw some very nice
positions and leeches yeah I have all
the training yeah and it's raining yeah
he still has he's still struggling to
use the entire board for for calculating
it will it fall it will come to him
don't worry
oh nice mate nicely done nice yeah but
Alicia says when you solve puzzles they
serve your puzzles from actual games
played on leeches yeah yeah so sometimes
you'll get a really weird puzzle that
wouldn't exist otherwise so if we check
out the tournament after at almost but
it's hour and 57
a lot of people without titles for
people without titles in the first top
10 but we clearly see that the mr. 1996
plays really fast
Burger King all the games 30 points but
front of Matthew the most impressive
could be speedy sloth he lost one game
Matthew and Matt really is having a
killer turn no no to drain you brain
drain you brain okay
I thought it will drain your brain but
they'll work he beat King crusher he
beat everyone actually Matthew only lost
one game as well yeah I know to someone
it's been so long ago ah to Oracle I
think with know what ago of our tomb
yeah let's check him out do you think
that they'd rather be playing real
bullet or do you think they they don't
mind playing - Plusle well I don't know
I mean usually I don't play - so at all
yeah I never played to play so but I
know III think that as I had a poll on
my channel and I asked to which time
control do you prefer the most and the
one that one by far was 3 + oh yeah so I
thought that's too much I thought it'd
be it'd be attracting to my too many
cheaters
so maybe 2 plus so was if you wanna play
board you can always bruiser k-- if you
need the longer time you're leaving
people the option to choose yes I'm a
gentleman mr. echo d8 who wants you to
say too weak too slow
yeah it's it's a it's a line from from a
famous game played on YouTube between
Magnus Magnus Carlsen and and fresh in a
the the Frenchman not raw for best
friend or something like that
why
the story of the couch is the story of
the couch will be revealed I hope next
next yeah next week but next Tuesday if
not then I will be very angry
oh the problems with a certain provider
yes the couch the couch provider it
seems like you have provider problems
yes a lot yeah but I don't think it's
it's any different to anywhere else so
one thing that I want to mention there
are more things I want to mention but
one of the things I want to mention is
if you are still interested in joining
the giveaway you can just comment on the
video where I mentioned the giveaway
it's the one with the towel on D on the
thumbnail and also it says 400,000
subscribers and it doesn't make sense
for you to make more comments if you
make 50 comments using F stacked all the
website we will be using to choose the
winners will filter out all of them and
it will only account for one of your
comments so there are a lot of people
like some of some of you posted hashtag
tile after the previous live stream
maybe like 20 or 30 times and it just
goes to the spam area of the comment
section so it doesn't help just you know
to save you the trouble
alright once again tries to win this one
box against box how to play age 5 here
for example all bulbs goes for the clean
win no no math is with no I met Matthew
yes see - such a nice move Queen yes yes
and why not Bishop check wow he really
messed it up hmm yeah he's ballpark's
really it 505 ah
Wow oh he tried to trick him
once again but large areas that would be
crazy okay nothing lost the game against
Yosef Yosef is really striking against
stronger Yosef in 2013 do you think
that's his year of birth he's 6 years
old yes yep well quite quite quite a
player yeah he's up against Parker won a
guy in shape yeah fix the screen layout
what's wrong with the screen layout yeah
what's wrong with the screen layout
shouldn't be anything wrong with the
screen layout but you know if if you say
there's something wrong I will check it
there shouldn't be anything wrong
nope it's it's all where it's supposed
to be I mean it's not a great screen
layout I know that but it's the way it's
always been
yeah mr. Larabee toaster says how to
make your tournament with money prizes
well you make a tournament and whoever
wins you give the money that's that's
how it works but first you gotta have
money so if you have money you can do it
you don't have to have money you can you
can you know get our sponsors okay or
you can give out hugs oh that's nice
yeah I always like that when you have
free hugs you know people with signs and
you know I've never seen one actually I
think that's in Croatia you know there
were a few of them once increase here
really in front of the bank here in the
center they were giving free hugs one
time I didn't get one I didn't need one
I mean okay I was doing okay in life you
know so people were like yeah putting up
signs but when you passed they just put
it down no everyone you know opens their
arms if you need a hug but uh you just
the hug no I didn't haven't declined it
they don't offer it first you have to go
and then they offer it I've seen some
photos where people did receive hugs
yeah I haven't seen it yet it will be
nice to see it actually no they probably
did it and it's sites I mean so a nice
gesture yeah that's okay so let me check
out the game against Petya KMC because
betacam see all right don't know I don't
think we've checked it really takes a
long time to load when you go for it for
the other tab that's really eternity
like that but it is kind of winning if
he had more time so it will be
interesting
okay going for the night and the d8
square tonight is a very nice piece and
now we just push the win oh all right
it's just completely winning capture
okay but even a pro okay
Oh point eight that's interesting yeah
it's interesting because you can easily
get your opponent into stalemate if
you're not really good at doing what
needs to be done which ptam she seems to
be but she doesn't go a lot yeah yeah
it's a draw I thought he had it
okay I mean it would be a nice victory
for him because a lot of them what he
didn't yeah that one as well yeah you
get two points for the draw a few
berserk ah we have a lot like Fredrik is
here okay you know yes he I think he
always joins okay he also berserks and
he is playing against the guy who now
drew the game against solo me iseul yes
salami Russell or something hanging in
there
yeah what's the first prize you mean the
first prize for winning the tournament
or the giveaway or to give away the for
the giveaway it's still to be revealed
mr. Oswald says am I scared to play in
my own tournament well no if you're a
follower on my channel you should know
that I have no problems with losing I
mean I enjoy chess you know what happens
happens but I will play the game yeah
this is more of a how-to set for
enjoying you know we just organized a
nice tournament people gather we have
over 5,000 people and we just drink some
soda and comment on the games yeah we do
and then we will be accepting some
challenges later and doing doing the
giveaway as we usually do mr. Jonathan
asks how to enter the giveaway well
that's that's you know something for
subscribers only so I would I would
guess you you are not a subscriber if
you do not know how to enter the
giveaway yeah that's actually mr. good
observation mr. Ethan Kokoda car called
car code car says that young looks like
Kuryakin I actually play like cartoon as
well yeah boring boring boring
positional chess but no seriously I
already said that a few times I like I I
really have a folder where you look
exactly like - where's that photo I want
to see I think it's some Facebook next
to the one you know where you're like
ripping off your shirt thank you next is
that one okay the popular ones when we
do the chair jokes
ah well after the tournament the
tournament is a very serious
think as we are paying so much attention
to it right now I mean I am I don't know
what you're doing not only the
tournament director
it seems a mr. whoa that's really weird
but I don't think anything actually
happened okay
but mister never enough it seems that he
caught up with everyone and he now faces
the night king I like in the first round
yeah my the first place maybe he can
beat him once again yeah is a who who in
the chat is also a fan of Game of
Thrones is everyone waiting for her for
Sunday since we're talking about the
night King evil says he's a subscriber
but he doesn't know how to enter the
giveaway well check out my not previous
video but the one before that and you
will all will be revealed boiler by
Johnny yeah Ryan yeah Young says that he
liked it before HBO to cover with the
writing yeah that is a bit I think that
happens around season 5 yeah yeah the
winds of the winds of winter still
hasn't been released and it doesn't look
like it will be released in this year
check out this idea if my character is
native to with my g4 and Bishop
everything yeah it definitely is worth
watching
whoa night King wins this one what the
night King wins against never enough
with a very nice idea so a second one oh
no I never enough one of the previous
one yeah very nice so what's the lineup
little plot can still still you know
keeping up with everyone
yeah but he got a little bit of a bad
street here yeah able to maintain the
fire and the Mathew finally lost his
streak Wow first he drew that he lost
yeah but it was a it was a nice streak
against watch s yeah see he's really
stirring trouble up in the top ok little
+ Canon Matthew okay oh that's a nice
pawn my g3 I wrote each one so that
would be a problem think that black is
ah he wants to push the pawn captures
captures oh nice that's interesting
if if black can't deliver checkmate if
my I really I thought you would go
between the Oh 25 got a nice idea Wow
okay now he just allowed checkmate but
there was no way around it yeah let's
check ya in a couple if you create that
draft around a second and so only two
more people in the top ten who are not
titled beta k MC and speedy sloth okay I
really think speedy slot will take this
one especially since nineteen berserk
and he's already down to 28 seconds yeah
this guy even though look at me nice
loss he's going very well
he's killing it I don't know what rock
g4 is doing but okay it doesn't matter
he can go Queen no okay that's a nice
pass pawn yeah it's 18 seconds I think
Knight king is looking to break $2,900
in this tournament but the PD slot
really makes it through
is he gonna pull the pawn and give up
the rook not much point in doing so but
okay okay okay but you have to defend
the bishop no you have to go for pro but
you don't have it yes the King can go
escape yeah now check King escapes via
the dark squares okay III can deal or oh
oh that's a nice hiding square no you
don't take the knight I think you have
to you have to but then rook just mates
I mean okay
speedy slot wasn't speeding up this game
Oh who's mr. Kranti Grandmaster Kranti
is here with all week home wins okay
okay very late but already Oh
again speed is loss against who is who
is Jim Kranti never heard of him
also no information about the country
probably also about the name so it's a
it's a mysteriously hidden player with
all the wins he plays a nice line where
he give up not super point by the be 5
points okay oh that's that's how you do
it yep that's young Koval says what
berserk King means that's pretty much it
yeah means the teen power and glory by
over meal
yeah well mning show superior talent
well that's a nice definition they say
they see Jim grunty's Carlson but I
don't think so
it's unless unless grunting means
something in Norwegian then I I guess it
is possible but I don't think it is
people okay so some Shane asks for a
King crusher game game okay after this
one hmm do you capture um Poisson and
give up the bishop or I think one was on
VIII's really yeah yeah that's shame
it's a whale III with mushroom before
okay but he could have given up the rook
just capture night and window bishop no
yeah so speedy sloth okay he sees it now
yeah because you told him yeah maybe he
watches this at the stream the crab not
looking good for GM Kranti the secret is
and we just praised him said he didn't
lose a single game so far so is speedy
the sloth too much of a challenge we'll
see I think we
when we show his game he yeah and we
gene stumbles yeah it's you give him the
spotlight and then he just feels the
pressure to do really good and then it
just doesn't work try too hard he is a
grandmaster so if it still impress us
with something we'll see he's thinking
but time is running out and and speedy
the sloth just you know doesn't man 96
but yeah that's true will be this will
this be the first game yeah this will be
the end of GM Kranti speedy the sloth
what a beast Wow Oh speedy everything is
attacked
what a beast speedy there's no way
around this and okay
GM Kranti loses yeah he relaxed a bit
too much he entered the top ten and then
he he thought he heard oh yeah but you
don't just enter top ten and play a bad
game against speedy the sloth enter King
crusher
so the ratio gained from him as long
okay all right uh-huh you see he their
algorithm shows you title players first
no it seemed okay so even if you you
know not you're not very rewarded for
forgetting any titles at least you know
leeches respect you at least in that
respect yeah okay King crusher didn't
preserve this 100 of them well but I'll
reserve this one yeah we'll see you know
fortune favors the brave
we'll see what happens okay
the night will be kicked away but to a
much nicer square you can just cemented
there and all is well
so King crusher going all out here yeah
just put the knife away in g4 no no too
early and what no no it's not possible
I think Queen b7 followed by some
sacrifice on an f3 maybe but he's not
good he's going for the for the pole for
the pawn and he's gonna get made it yeah
that's how just works
Wow yeah the one which should never grab
a pond now the g5 pawn Falls unless it
doesn't yeah the other route comes yeah
it was
Wow and now King h5 no Queen I trade
now he's gonna block it captures
captures and now go for some bad back
rank ideas if the King goes to f5 I'm
pretty sure white wins so yeah but hmm
okay yeah you can't block it now
yeah and now Rock d8 probably yeah come
on let Evan unless ya can get soldier 5
yeah it's over and okay checking me yeah
very nice well yep fortune favors the
brave
it would seem yeah King crusher didn't
really yeah but he's not having the best
of Germans also considering how many
games he's played I think he played the
most tournaments the most games in the
tournament so far yeah wow look at this
yeah also playing world and Munir Mangia
and I don't think that we actually seen
his game no and will we I don't know it
seems like been seeking is gonna okay
delaying a little bit
hmm okay there we have it
okay no that's and that's a weird now he
captures on f7 no he doesn't he could
have really if it was like really a
hyperbole or something but not for two
minutes
yeah this is real chess okay 600 oh very
nice okay
how many players are there now but don't
wait don't look now we look after the
game you know what I think it's probably
over five thousand yeah I think it is
over five thousand so that's a nice
result Bente
Vince Vince King and he probably has his
pin number there oh three oh one one
eight yeah for his iPhone yeah it
doesn't seem to be a year maybe unless
is unless it's 1918 like maybe maybe
he's 131 in hurry
yeah or the first of March yes 1918
just after the end of the World War one
you know probably played a nice
tournament in New York with the last
grand capablanca yeah
I mean it's not unreal there are people
who are a hundred and one and enjoy
chess that's it could happen I don't
think they'd be playing the whole GM
alive but to my knowledge it's you the
other Bach I think he's a hundred and
hundred and one or a hundred and four
but there you go
but it's good I don't know it maybe if
it is another but I think it is Super
Saiyan says he's a hundred and two and
he loves checkers Super Saiyan some coke
door says 98
okay no but I'm pretty sure other buck
yes passkey is pretty old but our buck
is older I actually so spassky life I
told you that yeah and when he opened
the tournament yeah yeah ah white offers
drop black declines drawn yeah
no draw he'll play this one minute and
more yeah of course
this opposition I've seen some some
people he took photos with Spassky I
don't know who posted it either either
I'm pretty sure someone posted a photo
with Spassky maybe last year somebody we
wanted to see may feel opinion once
again yeah we wanted to see how many
players are there oh there are five six
okay and we are already nearing the last
half an hour in the tournament so yeah
we can check it out let's let's check it
out and and if you in the chat have a
request for whose game you would like to
see okay there you have it of course you
do write it down yeah yeah do suggest
that you don't even have to use hashtag
suggestions too many mm plus rails
players well that's that's a good for
chess but if we look at the this okay
fill opinion is actually a good area
mm-hmm
oh oh he won right by okay adjournment
its I click here right yeah okay nice
good good programming show some low
rated games okay this can be considered
a lower rate of the game yeah 1700 is
this low enough yeah although I think
yeah that's that's a good for Filipino I
don't think he was this high rated yeah
better page 5 was a better move I would
say Mishra p2
[Music]
okay yeah okay just blockade that 94 95
96 Queen D for this Sabah phrases hello
everyone I hope you're having an
excellent day well I hope everyone is
having an excellent day I sure AM
yeah mine mine is fine only fine well we
do something about that drink some more
juice yeah I'm joking I had a pretty
pretty good today and yesterday was also
a good one but not not the greatest one
as you know we did go to the funeral so
that was very sad yeah but it happens so
other than that it was it was okay I
liked the video Robert in his game it
was a very personal game it was a really
a nice one against the Berlin especially
I had a privilege to actually to sit
next time when he was playing the game
because I'm the fourth table yeah yeah I
know I know the club so yeah that was
it's quite something but okay yeah I was
actually gonna show a game that I played
against him and I I played a very nice
game but he still beat me and but I
couldn't find the game I was actually
thinking about the the first memory I
had of him and the first time when I
came to the club I was like 13 years old
and he was there yeah he was there and
he was like the strongest player in the
club and the thing was the thing that I
remember was that he played the moves
like in such a way that he was like
always forcing me to go into a worse
position so whatever he did it was
always like a thing of like I could see
some good news but then he played the
smooth that was like really crushing me
and
yeah he was the rose from the player
yeah so I know I remember when I started
and I played some blitz games against
him like five plus or something and he
he asked me like what I enjoyed playing
I said okay I liked playing white for
example against the Sicilian and then he
would constantly play the Sicilian
against me and constantly beat me I
would attack attack a second he always
knew every possible mover how to defend
I was like okay you know how to play
okay you know yeah okay okay in the
spirit of Robert yeah in the spirit of
Robert yeah cheers to that
so what do we have here is Filipino
winning this yeah I mean not exactly but
if you judge by the time he could be
yeah but not he can just yeah okay and
now he should put the Ruby six maybe or
be six but okay just well there goes the
Queen that very the worst move you could
play
yeah but he's down to a second so it's
not not to be unexpected or not to be
not waiting to fill opinion all right
very nice that's probably going to top
500 or something yep and we are 5,700
people very nice
we might even cross 6,000 which would be
very nice and Patrick MC is in second
place
mmm-hmm it's really nice considering
there are two I knowledge three
grandmasters playing there are three
grandmasters in the top ten I think for
four are playing for yeah there's also
the one that lost to the speedy sloth
Fernando says guy in the back blink
twice if you are being held hostage are
you here against your will
where is the rakia oh well we could have
yeah I mean we could have won its
it is customary on this channel you have
to have some rakia so I actually do have
a nice one so I'll just go get it be
right back okay yeah that's that that
was a great idea a great great idea
okay I don't know if Tao ever drink some
rakia yeah
rocketed if it was your idea very well
did tal ever drink some rocket do you
know of course yeah after he drank the
rakia fluently the thing with rakia is
when you drink it to your fluent in
every language so you're a man of the
world sometime so do you usually drink
it before before okay no no why not
too many too many yeah but okay now it
will be only the one so it's okay yeah
you never know
exactly okay what do we have here
there's a piece for white mister
Grandmaster going at it
Oh for the rooks oh whoa nice a nice
tactic and the GM wins alright here it
is you get the big one yeah there's a
big one okay mol-1 what are we drinking
it's well you said
if you don't want to go over over the
first one so if you like it I can get
you another one but it's a nice nice
nice fruity one yeah you can try and
guess what it is and but you can also
select the game okay
ah we have love you and you love me feed
a master have not seen a game by him yet
exactly so we are going to try to do
that okay games from people we haven't
seen against the desert eagle who is a
weakest supporter so let's see how he
does
and she reserved he burger to death
always love to see a game from leeches
supporter yeah
interestingly there is no supporter
tournament well like I thought they'd be
doing that like it could be a thing you
know
you mean like the best supporter yes the
strongest supporter yeah yeah actually
when you mentioned it's it's a good idea
yeah or maybe they do have it I just
haven't seen it
alright man also haven't heard uh didn't
guess what it is but yeah you can also
try to guess what it is
maybe I've tried try it yeah enjoy okay
likewise man it's a nice mild blend
don't have a clue yeah I would say it's
a grassy one no it's not it's you know
it grows on a tree it grows on the
trachea and it's nope not not a plum
nope mmm I'll give you a hint it's gross
well it grows everywhere I mean we have
one here but it should you know it's
much better if it's grown near the
seaside no it's not no it's not an olive
I wouldn't say it's a lemon let's see
what the people think oh we have a we
have an apple we have a fig we have weed
no it's not weed but great yes it's a
nobody to go there okay well you're
messing around
ah Desert Eagle one again Wow
Desert Eagle what a way to win a game
especially for a supporter it is he not
in the top ten
no but he is beating beating people from
the top ten okay so I think we haven't
seen game from arson 23 and speedy slot
still keeping at it night King still
didn't break 2900 since he drew two
games in a row other than that he only
okay forget no not the way yeah this win
is a win the first win then I draw okay
let's see a game from mr. arstan against
mr. Kiril Tina just wants to enjoy the
show yeah there was there was this one
guy when I started my youtube channel
and the the one summer where I streamed
every day there was this one guy and he
was uh he was really a pervert like he
would say the nastiest stuff and that
yeah for some reason YouTube didn't like
grayed out okay and everyone got used to
him already it was like for the for the
tenth day in row that I was streaming he
would just show up and he even had his
name was like I'm not dad but it was
like Robert the pervert and he just came
in he said the nasty stuff you know okay
so it's really really weird white is
trying to get a together helmet still
made out of this but he's not doing all
that great okay but it was a nice idea
with the bishop day six yeah but now
it's far from it
checkmate okay our son takes the win no
he lost yeah yeah how are we doing can
anyone catch up tonight King well
previously he had 30 points lead but now
it's 20 yeah it is possible is it can
you go to the second page can we see if
there's anyone creeping up on them
fishing pole definitely having a nice
streak also dark cool keeping it in
Kranti Grandmaster Kranti almost then
Grandmaster Federico still yeah he wins
pretty much all the games but doesn't he
breaks the streak yeah and doesn't
berserk
the third one little Plotkin okay Eric
Rosen Eric Rosen is in 22nd games in a
row
yeah but he's berserk and all of them so
yeah tough dirty game stuff for well he
kind of started losing yeah to it cling
to dirty it would seem yeah okay let me
just see the the one after that and the
one in the top 50 okay she just player
Potter okay and what do we have in the
in the top 50 Zuber Thomas who beats
uh-oh oh but he lost four games in a row
Wow which one is is that from the United
States
no but the heels started pretty late I
would say not so many games yeah and
then he had a he had a bad a bad break
but I don't know who that is yeah yeah
Benito Camila very funny
it means like vanish and someone donated
some money and then he said that the
name was Bonita famila and people do
that sometimes and then I read it and
then it's a you know really funny so you
you can never be too sure that's why I
read it I mean of course I've heard
about it but I don't know if you've ever
watched How I Met Your Mother
yeah
and then you know when Ted the work says
and as a professor as an architecture
professor and then he has this girl from
China in his class and she has like the
weirdest name when you pronounce it in
English and then he pronounces name is
his like yeah of course yeah that's her
name there's no way that's her name
isn't she like starts crying and runs
out okay because I can't remember the
name but it's uh it's a funny in English
you know you can never be too sure what
someone's name is okay that's a nice
passport okay just put the man yeah okay
mister even tip even even ttip I it's
cuckoo
yeah that's her name cuckoo so and then
he starts laughing and then she's you
know rise and and leave so that's why
that's why I never assumed someone's
name is something other than what it is
do a charity tournament for three-plus
so all winners choose a charity their
prize money goes to and cheaters will be
discouraged to play okay that sounds
fair
I think it's a good idea for the next
tournament yeah mr. old oh six Kili show
the game from the last page I think the
guys from the last page is stopped
playing yeah I don't think yeah maybe
even people who accidentally joined and
very very cute not playing but yeah it
would be interesting to show one
definitely but yeah okay let's see here
yeah it's almost six thousand people a
lot of people are without points and not
playing these are people who just joined
okay 300 mr. Hayter see you later haters
see you later how is he reading these
well they are right there yeah okay
that's can I please host an under 2,000
tournaments so of course I would be very
glad to host such a tournament okay my
king really killing it this tournament
let's let's see him because August beta
this is it if he takes down beta which
will be the case he does have more time
and we saw that he was a really
experienced flagger okay yeah it's a
draw
yeah hotel mates nice nice and it really
takes a lot of a night things rating 11
points for a draw
he was so close to twenty nine hundred
twenty five points for twenty minutes
isn't reachable but look at the Bronte
Kranti haha
sometimes on the second page and now
already yeah let's check out his game so
against for chess okay ooh some Bishop
286 action going on but grunty ignoring
and Vova spent almost no time for such
an attack and he has a rook on g3 that
means castles rook e1 nice relief
through G 3 then night huh yeah how did
that happen I want to know that the line
seems like my kind of line how did you
get there okay if if grunty loses yet
another game that we're showing we are
no longer watching his games I think we
are also because he can show a leak a
Vova so it's show both of them and it
cancels its I it cancels you know the
the jinx out
okay
mr. accelerator terrible fear of flying
and watching my games not my case but my
videos okay I just got with Netflix but
you know I guess I guess it serves the
purpose who is my favorite American
chess player
well I would have to go with Bobby
Fischer definitely unless you're
referring to the ones that that are
still alive but if they are who would
you say if they are what referring to
the people who are alive I don't know I
have no idea yeah but more falafel
American so it's a not an easy choice
you know yeah but from the ones that are
alive it's yeah definitely hard to say
[Music]
well it would be and I'd be silly to
choose anyone from the from the top
player so I have seven check me but it
was check yeah this is actually jokes
around your channel okay video he
actually made two part video okay just
like a like bloopers and stuff ah mister
Les Mis yes okay maybe this will be part
of yeah yeah kind of afraid of making
mistakes on them yeah I'm a grandmaster
would miss the queen of seven checkmate
unless unless it was a check by by black
first okay what do we have here yeah you
never know
Kremlin mister checkmate won a lot of
people have there's a classical game so
Fritz but even to call so mr. Duggan's
talent mate in one
yeah
yeah sure there are many many such
occasions and how to stop the poem haha
ix 92-93 was an option but okay and one
of my favorites
carpal vs buddy F where it's completely
drawn endgame well there is there are
moves to be played and then but I've
just a last carp of mate in one really
really awesome game 15 more minutes and
okay it seems to be filtering out all
the players in the top 10 are now rated
except speedy sloth what I what a guy
speedy only deserves to such a touch
against the fishing pole the legend mr.
sloth have you seen the the cartoon the
Zootopia yes yes with the really not
speedy slots you know working as yeah I
don't know if it's like the Department
of Motor Vehicles or something like that
yeah but they really portrayed it well
it's always like thank you when I reach
some office everyone's a sloth okay to
pawn it versus no pawns that's what you
get when you live in creation yeah the
baroque
when Miguel is asking when is the meme
review coming out well only better but
there are well a lot of memes going on
now unread it but I'm still waiting for
a few more to show up then we can you
know Oh doing a nice review but I don't
think it's gonna happen anytime soon we
need at least like 50 of them or a
hundred yeah what do you think about
Korchnoi
fortunately what a player really
terrible yeah there's I recently seen an
interview by Korchnoi where he just
mentions you know what's what's it like
being a grandmaster in Soviet Russia
what's it like to prepare for to play
against someone like Karpov you know
what people expect from you and
it's just very tough you know if you
don't win when you don't eat yeah yeah
it's like that okay
okay tonight King versus that sounds
dressed yeah yeah it is
okay against the GM which week yeah whom
we haven't seen a game yet they're
saying replicas opera ISM I don't think
I don't think Frederick is opera vision
operas oh yeah and people just want to
maybe see a provision play here I have a
good win against opera vision yeah yeah
it's the only one I have in which time
in hyperbole of course and we played
over 100 moves even the end game really
yeah yeah it's a really really an
intense game okay probably pretty fast
you will need a mouse such as this one
yeah but it was played on a different
Mouse oh yeah it's pretty much the same
mouse this is like the newer edition of
the of the mouse which you know has a
nicer texture and also it shinier but I
don't know if it's the better one I
should write down the good games in the
tournament and do an analysis of them
well I don't need to write them down as
they are all saved in the into the
leeches servers but no I did show them
yeah I did show game by the previous
winner of one of the term it's a
provision one one of them and then I
show the game he played over the board
his real games you know from classical
chess but they were really really fancy
attacking games so really enjoyable to
show them oh okay okay
check but is it though yes
no worries white is trying but I mean it
has 30 seconds yeah good game mr. picker
all's but tonight King rain
supreme 11 more minutes and there will
be a battle for the second let me just
check or you check your the tournament
director I believe this is the first
tournament ever where we have over six
six thousand people okay so that's I
think that's a record okay I don't think
it's a record unleashes because you have
like the the yearly shield arenas which
yeah but last for 24 hours but this is
very nice
okay we do have once again speedy sloth
hanging in there without a toggle here
more ABC chess analysis YouTube okay
another youtuber let's see oh yeah I I
think you know no but I've seen him on
leeches I think we even played once
maybe we can easily check that nope oh
yeah there's no screen come on
okay yeah did we know okay we lost it no
he went way but okay let's just check
quickly know how is Ella played uh we
haven't okay what do you want to check
yeah I thought maybe check Rosen but
he's he's struggling with with Burger
King yeah he's here still in the in the
top twenty okay against the dragon
dragon well by alright mr. Rosen let's
see let's see how we do
you have a good score against dragon
belt yeah I was like one two three four
five five two two so should be good and
dragon will be is actually thinking a
lot about this well not not longer than
generic as he is up on time that's
that's not a whole Rock oh you mean the
one white grabbed yeah yeah but ninety
seven but the knife cannot go too far um
so maybe only in exchange okay and he he
has to go eight four
you usually need to get the rook into
the game and how do you free the night
you don't know you don't do it and now
II for know I'm just thinking okay maybe
something okay she wants to fix the pawn
structure she wants to enjoy his extra
exchange not extra changes the exchange
yeah seems seems to be working out for
him
you want to capture that no he captures
with the pawn that was weird
the black king is in a difficult
situation yep how do you okay well it's
nothing serious but hmm
well white is bad before you just the
black has no idea see right I believe
but captures captures check King you
want me to you want maybe better okay
okay yeah no he didn't see it okay route
characters and then we'll capture some
before no wow I really miss a lot what
they will play although I don't think
mine was a worse yeah you have to flag
him okay okay nice one by rosin what
else
no I see well let's see who's up for
grabs
mmm let's go to the top 50 yeah okay we
just split a saucer oh yeah any any game
is good there is no bad game he's up
against Mike we have 7 minutes and 13
seconds to go logical game logic is
playing uh I know which user name is
Hieu yeah I don't know either
but I'm sure Colonel Dino knows he knows
everything mr. mastermind yes we are
always checking the chat every message
there was a written we have seen it most
of them
aha chunk it is time for a cigarette
cabbage yeah we lost the cabbage where
is cabbage cabbage eating do you
remember what the cabbage attack is yeah
little one well yeah cabbage was a
legend okay what now black wins easy
easily okay and even a mate Wow okay the
greatest game for for the pot sir
firstly sputtering away okay we have
five more minutes let's return to the
top ten I believe okay yeah yeah let's
see nineteen not getting closer to
twenty nine hundred but a lot like
Fredrik is in second place
we're joking every game so yeah if it
was if it was bullet and he was a Burger
King every game he maybe could have a
chance to catch up to nineteen but not
with with the hypo buit the - yeah but
we what who is Desert Eagle in the top
ten
yeah he's just having a nice game
against Kranti okay
Kranti and the Kranti isn't even berserk
king but he's very long time
Knight here okay
go there and what now yeah terrible move
this f5 Wow ninety-four after day yeah
yeah a nice save
nice save but
by mr. Conti hmm yeah but time is time
is going away oh he tried to calculate
it will will he be able to put the phone
yeah and that's he won't try to grab the
other points oh okay push push and bh7
yeah but just push and h1 wins okay it's
a bit of a different strategy that there
was just g5 was winning what's happening
this is new life oh my god Wow no it's
some GM power right there even want the
point with chick okay
Wow check grab the pawn at least the
pawn ground alive ha I mean even if I'm
pre moving for the point to get to h1
how do you play that there's no way for
the pond to go back I think was a mouse
slip maybe
yeah it's mr. Geum Kranti should really
consider getting a better Mouse yeah
moments like these you really can't
afford to have a bad mouse and it really
will take a lot from his rank see he
could have gotten to top five but did
you notice one thing mr. Slauson in the
top 10 oh no where is sloth 13th place
okay
but he might yeah I don't think he'll be
joining the top ten okay sir three
minutes ago it's only fair I guess to
watch the games from the top guy yeah he
deserved it after all night King
deserves it
okay we see the game from the first and
the second okay and he's up against a
white frederick so should be an
interesting game no top 10 anime battles
good think we have an enemy expert here
we do yes okay
Dino is an expert on anime o'night King
already won okay what he won a piece in
how much 13 moves Wow okay well that's
likely very strong very strong and all
the gems are now in top ten except the
one where that the one we lost
yeah could I mention the gems by name I
could if I knew their names but I don't
I only know the one as they are playing
incognito speed is lost in the night
King maybe the last game of this hoster
kappa blanka says does the guy in the
back know any opening theory do you know
any opening theory yeah me neither
I'm very bad at opening theory but
openings are overrated it's true just
you know play some moves and then go for
the endgame that's not a real chess it's
it's actually a mandatory for this dream
not to know opening theory yeah I can't
with the question who is night king guys
really brush up on your Game of Thrones
yeah play some leeches no but we know
who night king is yeah he's the only gym
that we know who it is
yeah okay there there is actually a
cheat sheet in the in the chat who
making is somebody I won't say who but
we said it I know but I don't remember I
don't remember really who is the guy in
the back that's the hoodie guy the guy
in the back
the guy in the back is the night king
playing on his phone yeah someone
spelled it in Cyrillic botanique
please explain your love for the Evans
gambit
well dear sir you cannot explain love
you know that's true attack on titan do
you watch it I've heard of it but I
can't remember what it is it's an anime
but from 2013 yeah yeah I don't know
yeah ok I will check it out definitely
that's it what that's it ok but we will
wait for 2 minutes before we announce
anything our team here is 19 no it's not
if not I for Tamiya was my thing it
would be 100% wins although I haven't
seen artemiev even plays bullet but why
wouldn't he I mean yeah why wouldn't
anyone play bullet one thing's for sure
I need to watch some anime
yeah even this weekend yes and be sure
to watch Castlevania it's really really
sick ok really awesome take it into
consideration yeah we do know who who
night King this but ok we're just gonna
wait for a couple of more seconds till
all the games finish until everything is
filtered out I I don't think we had a
cheater here so in the end dota is life
managed to grab the 10th place ok very
nice interesting no three players
without a title yeah and someone might
grab more
places as the some of these games are
still being played perhaps
yeah but the tournament is over so pro
shouldn't they ah yeah yeah yeah
probably but I'm still gonna wait a
minute so yeah but because of the
cheaters yeah because of the I
don't think anyone in the top ten
cheated as there are so many losses but
we'll see how many games did night King
lose one two three four four games not
bad only four games Letson how is that
an 80% win rate because of the draws
because of the draws yeah really I think
so but he didn't have the all that many
draws expected to be higher but okay a
lot like Fredrik in second place and
Matthew okay will read them out or a lot
be after we get a confirmation that
everything was in order and everything
is cool first twelve first twelve
participants uh yeah
first second third fourth sixteenth yeah
six to twelve
I actually didn't make that Lee just
made that so but I was okay with it so
you approved yeah okay so to the
official part now the tournament has
successfully finished and after two
hours of play of the time plus of the
two plus zero time format we have the
winners the first the top three prizes
go to GM 1996 who I believe already
participated in one of the tournaments I
think he wants second place in the one
that penguin one and phir aaja was in
third place I believe that was the the
lineup then we have an international
master a lot like Fredrik in second
Matthew G p4p in third and then as
follows international mastermind Romania
then Grand Master never enough in fifth
Desert Eagle in sixth fish and Poland
seventh Grand Master
Kranti in eighth then candidate master
elm 2007 or it's 2007
that's an all or a zero and the dota is
life in number ten and since we have 12
money prizes also we have patriarchy MC
who was in the top for the entire
tournament but didn't manage to finish
the way he hoped for and speedy sloth in
12 still gaining the money price $10 but
you know it's it's the first loss yeah
for SWAT that's a lot and then some of
the others for the top 20 are stun 23
feed a master then feed a master Joseph
2013 ABC Ches Anna analysis YouTube in
15 Eric Ross and in 16th internet from
masters uber in 17th Alexander Ljubljana
in 18th also international nest freedom
astral love you and you love me 19th and
she'll keen
VK candidate master in 20 so it seems
that in the tournament we've had six
thousand two hundred and thirty seven
people which is by far the record so far
it's a very impressive number and I will
of course save this when I finally
finish my website this will all be safe
for all the history to remember and I
will of course publish all of the
winners in my other social media and
Facebook Twitter maybe even Instagram
we'll see how it goes
and of course be sure to congratulate
everyone for their very nice victories
as you know it's always nice to win and
receive congratulations but it's also
nice to congratulate others that have
earned it you know people should really
learn that so do be sure to congratulate
them and yeah that's about it I think we
can now do you have anything to add
maybe for for the end of the tournament
the juice was nice the juice is nice yes
okay yeah and of course congratulations
to the to the winners and hope you
enjoyed it I really had a great time
of course we're continuing with the
stream because we have to proceed to the
giveaway yeah yeah no it's not 905 and
yeah I can we'll be accepting some
challenges I'm gonna play a few games as
well and maybe in some 25 minutes we'll
start with the giveaway or no maybe
maybe get rid of the giveaway and then
just up until finish it up yeah and then
we just okay if anyone who finished in
the top 12 12 is perhaps following the
chat you can just message me on leeches
with your accounts and your email so you
can be presented with a price if not
tomorrow when I'm all done
you know resting up I will contact you
and request the information required for
for me to give out the prizes so that's
it with which the tournament I guess
some some challenges are in order
okay do you want to start first after
I've told you didn't play a game don't
know okay you make a fee oh you want to
play a game later okay you play first
I'm gonna have some juice and then I'm
gonna accept some challenges okay so no
challenge away okay you can challenge in
a different tab just so I have this one
saved okay so yeah you can just do it
like that
okay deleted is there an option in
chrome just duplicate my tab no yeah
alt-enter should it should be no no not
working no but did you hit Enter
no for some reason why isn't it selected
why isn't what selected this it is you
just deleted it okay so what I don't
know yeah we make it return no we do
this yeah but that you have a Mac so
yeah you have that weird action button
yeah yeah comment yeah I never enjoyed
those so once again it will be the
casual game so no rated games and the
first one is go says right-click on the
tab and press duplicate yeah I wish that
were true
yes okay we learn something yeah I like
the streams where I learned something
about the knowledge increased oh it's
not like I spent all my time in chrome
so I wouldn't know yeah but I never you
know it never came to me maybe
right-click on it yeah I just do the
control T and then just paste it yeah
what I do is you put it here so late at
all tantrum then duplicate yeah but wow
so many options here yeah you didn't
tell me
Wow okay Wow Chrome still has to be you
know a lot of things to discover in
Chrome oh that's c4 but c5 we're going
to play sharp without a nice sharp game
now after seeing all of those bullets or
two plus cell games this seems kind of
slow but okay yeah but you know better
better for it to be slow and we can
learn from it yeah in d6 a move you can
learn from really you're gonna capture
that well the first point Falls okay he
doesn't want it oh he's given me the
pony actually hmm he doesn't want to
pump but he gives me and well now he
will punish you you know no good
discoveries to be made before doesn't
work you're good but I actually think if
you played it it'd be good nope that's
rock you won if I'm you mean maybe would
be seven so it's a pawn it's just a
bones I will see where do you register
for the giveaway oh that's uh mr. Lynx
that's top secret but no it's not top
secret but it's something a subscriber
would know so a special excellence
yes especially an excellent subscriber
Thank You mr. Luca Luca Luca didn't
thank you very much
which is favorable leeches or Ches calm
no that's a question well it's it has
something for everyone you know each of
them I'll be right back okay you try try
out both of them and then you see which
you like more than just it okay
currently I am a piece up and with a
clear win with this past pawn so I'm
going to try to finish this quickly and
not a queen is always good to have even
though it's free so don't worry about
that play rook e7 but these seven is
here cannot play the rook to e7 now it's
not metal its meadow okay and we do have
90 challenges with me just so once again
guys rated games not accepted also when
we are playing the casual ones let's
keep it 3 plus oh and less okay so let's
play a ball game it will be fast enough
after this now we don't have the 2200
here anymore but still we are going to
try our best playing against whatever
row okay always a Sicilian c5
immediately ninety five a six ninety six
beautiful stuff Queen d1 best move
okay no d5 No hmm maybe I didn't play
this correctly
that's not a good queenside castle okay
there should be six now the giveaway
will start after we accept a few
challenges so don't worry we didn't give
away anything yet
okay
let's get over rid of this very very
strong Knight rook c8 with rook c5 yeah
he can capture hero waking of six ro G
for double up pressure here okay that's
the form please I can give up at least
one point d5 would be four seems nice
no oh should play faster
that's a win on time very nice matter is
back yeah that was a quick walk do you
want to play a game ok ok let's do it ok
they want to play three plus so yeah now
you're in for a treat but you just
grabbed my juice let's see what you
learned in your wake of playing chess
yeah come and sit in check play yeah
only no yeah never drink during the
stream only after it okay you're playing
against each count
1508 player doesn't matter he does more
reading let's see what's going on okay
yes you can still participate if you
Hanuman is here if you write a comment
with a hashtag tile in the one of the
videos not one of the videos it has to
be the video the video that I would
guess contains tile in the thumbnail but
that's just my guess there are so many
videos that contain Tao in the thumbnail
I'll get the latest one yeah I call it
the Tony oh yeah oh meeting Rajas here
man was he in tournament I haven't seen
him no me neither
meeting rod why weren't you playing in
the tournament and we we missed you in
the stream come on man you
obviously always the first guy who says
hello or something yeah oh yeah you can
actually still participate anyone can
participate as when when I start to give
away the the website I will be using
it's just a website that randomly uses a
youtube comment and then if that comment
has a hashtag tile in it then you do win
do you wait so for now I will disclose
it will be nine prizes with a with a $25
Amazon gift card so you can buy a book I
mean for $25 you can buy a very nice
book i ordered an ice chest book today
but it's not about chess
it's tolls wife seller land or the
actress the russian actress if she wrote
a book on on her life would me call top
and I was like I must have that and I
ordered it and it was like I think it
was around $17 so I mean for $25 you can
get you can get a nice book even a
hardcover one or you can just get a
bunch of non hardcover books that also
works and the the the the first nine
prices will be $25 Amazon gift card and
the top price will be two hundred and
fifty dollars amazon gift card where you
can really get anything you want
either a nice chess set or some learning
material for your chess just you know
anything you enjoy even maybe our
life-sized Bobby Fischer action figure
if it will exist but still still waiting
for that one to come true save the gift
card just for that yeah okay so it is
just move on phone yeah it's easier to
move on the phone yes don't say that to
my mouse first yeah if I put it the
fastest I can't control the mouse it's
really too fast I mean judging by the
thing you said so that you started
playing a week ago I would say it's
going pretty well
yeah no no he's always
ends up in a better position but he
waits a long time you know that's it Oh
guys the nice seven nice yeah he does
well and now we can go Knight captures
g7 maybe complicated yeah it's just a
nice move to me that's the worst thing
you can do on this tree which jump is is
the correct one but that's actually okay
ah he has to capture Bishop e5 no black
has to capture and you have to capture
yeah but now the night is a little bit
of micro what you not to do it yeah but
that's okay I mean it's better to losing
time than on a blunder yeah even though
you're a piece down yeah you know can go
for another one and then we do the
giveaway and then yeah so you can you
know breathe through it feels good man
clap do you know do you only play five
minutes oh yeah okay we have a person
here sestina looks like Robert Hoffman
who's Robert I don't know but he he
looks like him
okay whoa that's some modern defense
stuff which one would be 65 exchanging
the Queens on d8 okay but feelsgoodman
Club declined it
Oh meeting Raj says he played 15 to 20
games played somewhere around 25 and he
had to leave me 50 and if you remember
the first time we streamed the meeting
Raj joint and he was like 1700 if you
remember yeah I don't remember the
rating but yeah remember him yeah I know
he's over 2,100 very strong yeah I play
play with him from time to time yeah oh
that's that's not a good one at some
point some pawns are poisonous but
feelsgoodman crappier he sees it oh no
us don't allow it immediately sacrifice
all the pawns
yeah no you know capture the pawn
actually I would capture with anything
at this point and now you will Roxy and
you against time that activity that's
how you play two pawns in a piece for
activity yeah it's super active okay and
black is almost fully developed no he's
not but you know are you are you making
sure you're only accepting non rated
games because it's my rating went down a
bit
yeah I know and it was more than this
yeah really
yes okay
oh they're taking control of the
darkness where they like it exactly with
the idea of what Queen Jack may be okay
Bishop goes on g7 if he has luck yeah
but he can well he's dead lost but you
know but hey baby you win on time maybe
he can but you know I don't oh nice nice
that's that's a good move yep no way
around it seems like mr. fields good man
clap is really strong very strong player
yep some some alpha zero level play here
okay we have a confirmation from all six
Keeley the rating was 1952 when you
started taking challenges so it hasn't
changed
really yeah since the beginning of the
stream yeah I would also say that it was
okay alright well thank you sir for the
confirmation thank you for such a why we
we almost got in trouble so you saved us
yeah really care about my blitz rating
for our training in general but you know
that's not why I I don't allow you to
play but it's against the rules you know
yeah HS will ban me if I we all play on
my account start playing with the a pond
maybe you stalemate I'm gonna stalemate
or something yeah you should start
playing with the main room
do you want one okay
I do the giveaway now and
we continue okay good game good game man
enjoy it was a good game yeah man give
him he'll okay let's chop how do we do
it
seems it seems like you can only operate
the mouse from this chair from which
chair yeah okay so this is how we do it
here's your soda beer now as usual we
will now choose the winners of the
giveaway sorry here we go man by the
same rule we always use so this is the
website we'll be using I already tested
it once you can see that here in my
testing yet you don't see it yet because
of the delay but here we will just read
load okay let's go some control or we
will do it here
copy paste that's the the link to my
video and ok I will make sure you see it
I probably will have to enlarge it a bit
but yeah I'm pretty sure you can see it
here you can see that it will filter
duplicate users and here we will get
youtube comments so here let's get all
the comments from the video it will now
check how many comments there are in the
video so let's do it
ok 13 1400 1500 - lets see the comments
yeah everyone wants that juicy giveaway
prize do yeah you actually find comments
and then it if they have hashed at all
yeah this site doesn't offer the option
of searching for hashtags all in the
comments but it doesn't matter since
pretty much everyone has it so the way
it goes first we pick nine people for
the $25 Amazon gift card and then one
last person the 10th person for the two
hundred and fifty dollars amazon gift
card here we have as usual the mighty
notepad there you have it yes
from 1 to 9 there will be $25 and number
ten that's two hundred and fifty dollars
so let's
arch this part of the screen so you can
see it do it like this let me just see
there's a there's a delay so I will have
to wait a bit but 20 seconds yeah I
think it's more of a 17 but it does say
so but you can see the entirety of it
but you will see the name that that is
chosen so let's start it's a start
raffle and pick random winner let's
start the first winner of the Amazon
gift card no don't write hashtag down
now it's a it's in the video that's the
best part yeah what is the dream your
beer is powerful thank you sir I know
okay
they are flying around let's see this is
a Stalin Jesus the winner of the first
prize is a matzah STR he said in the
comment hashtag Tao means more are good
matter videos yes it does but whatever
you wrote it would also mean more about
master videos so doesn't really matter
the congratulations sir for the first
prize there we have it you are going
into the mighty notepad mister a maza
str of course i will try a sense youtube
no longer allows you to contact other
users via nickname you'll have the
contact to me we are some sort of media
but if by any chance you don't I will do
my best to contact you as usual and
since the last time here we have pick
another winner this wasn't here before
we had the wrong now we just click pick
another winner and we go start yeah yeah
yeah we do okay all right second winner
of the giveaway is condo taro I'm Ellen
Gro h4 was covered by the Knight f4 only
move but he doesn't have hair stacked
all in it unfortunately unfortunately
for the winner
Mahlon grow he is not the winner of the
price we must choose another winner yeah
yes the entire comment is always shown
so we have to choose another one yep
we have Jimba 2007 I love how hash
textile is very inventive and creates
out of nothing PS love the channel
hashtag a matter from a local high
school chess coach in Illinois
hashtag tal is there as you can see it
yes see how it even highlights it I
think there so did this because of me
you know I think I'm gonna be so nice I
think I'm the only one actually using
this website commoner Picard yeah I mean
I just Google pick random comments and
this is the first one so let's pick
another winner congratulations to mr.
coach from Illinois
okay brush nice hashtag tall game avid
matter and congrats on 400 K soon you'll
be so famous you'll be having guest GM's
on your shows well with young and
Tincher who needs a GM on the show
exactly but it would be it would be nice
you know for them to join us for a beer
or two we'll definitely consider such
such an event okay third person going
into the mighty note bed there we have
it Josiah or Josie a brush let's pick
another winner yeah you had the right
hair stacked all in one of the 100 whoa
that's a big name extract um nice game
it's artificial intelligence mania
so congratulations mister artificial
intelligence mania you are the fourth
winner of the Amazon gift card let's go
no one a winner from India well it's
random so and I'm sure maybe there is
yeah ever no don't count a good matter
would love to okay how does YouTube even
allow his comments that's very
impressive but he does hashtag it does
have hashtag tall so it does go well
into the into the rules of the giveaway
yeah so mr. Donkey Kong
proved you are the winner yeah I mean
there was no rule against swearing or
anything like that and maybe it's it
doesn't mean that which we think it
means you know English is such a rich
language it could mean a lot of things
yeah you know so I guess yeah it's it's
fair
mr. Donkey Kong oh man yeah okay
we have armor I'm Ritesh with some with
some dots here okay so he is definitely
going into the notepad it would seem we
have give away his pieces Michael Todd
used Sakas King when he was a kid my
favorite player of all time which he was
born in this era so that we might might
even see an engine named tall sack 2.0
yeah would be nice but everything is in
order half stack tall is here so you go
into the mighty notepad there we go
I'm red - yeah there was a tall move I
did not expect yeah I was quite a move
all right let's see it Zachary ha
brought mechanic Mia which tall was a
fine pianist like I am well
congratulations to you sir on your piano
skills mr. Zachary huh Brad okay website
stop trolling me you go into the notepad
there we go
Zachary is in let's pick another one
okay we have to start it as well
okay I may be allowing a bad precedent
but you know it's not against the rules
I did say you just have to write
something about Tao maybe you will
specify the rules differently next time
maybe I will maybe I won't if you are
seeing this comment you are an excellent
comment reader after seeing some nice
tile games hashtag tile alright man
I truly abide there we go you go into
the mighty notepad congratulations sir
another winner of the $25 Amazon gift
card and we have number nine the last
winner before the main prize let's see
it yeah maybe it was meant as a joke I I
mean I don't think he meant it yeah I
like anything else Tao is the ghost to
be honest all right mr. squirrel chaser
no squirrels chaser no yes squirrel
chaser so he's not satisfied with only
one squirrel yeah all right mrs. Gilmore
yes mr. squirrels chaser tall is the
goat well said and now for the final
winner let's see okay and for the 250
but $50 Amazon gift card we have Max
Contreras
he really had us going in that Evans
gambit opening hatch tactile yeah I
don't think I really had you opening I
actually think you were expecting it for
to really be and I'm a game good game
but thank you forget for that so the
winner of the top prize 250 $50 Amazon
gift card goes to max Contreras Congrats
congratulations man there you go here
you go number 10 we saved the mighty
notepad over here so you don't see where
I keep all my stuff on desktop there we
go winners very nice alright that's that
and we do have some 20 minutes left in
the screen okay so and we're gonna keep
this tab open so we can just publish all
the winners on my other social
Media and of course be sure to
congratulate everyone so that's pretty
much it
let's accept a few more challenges do
you have beer do you want beer
I do have beer all right I do have beer
and I see that you have beer and it's I
think it's dry time for you to accept
some challenge play a game all right
let's do it
maybe some crazy opening or something
yeah maybe we'll see how it goes okay
seven days maybe not for now
unlimited nope let's play a few shorter
ones yeah
shorter ones are more fun too two
minutes okay why no one having any other
language other than English selected not
sure what you mean by that
yeah me neither
okay what do we go for so cheers to
everyone drinking truths or beer no
after the tournament it's so funny I was
about d5 that's a nice move oh I faced
that over the board not so long ago and
it was a very tough game oh I playing
against the Macedonian player yeah
against Luca what do you think okay all
right fair enough
Bazar Luca okay
well let's make it fun let's just grab
here whoa okay didn't expect anything
less go all into the attack okay he
keeps his King all the way in there
let's just castle here no let's go f5
just a nice nice Center
do I know how to play go no not really
I would love to learn but I don't know
how to play it unfortunately let's just
Castle here if you capture so I'll just
have a nice open F file does Yun have a
chess channel as well I I've heard he
does yes yeah it's not a very active one
but he does have it let's go here on e3
seems like a nice nice square Jana is
taking a little bit of a vacation but
soon there will be video streams and
everything so you are you are working on
your chest yeah yeah like a like a
madman just every day all day that's
mister the winner of the tournament is
night king what what a beast
okay I just I will grab a rook I don't
mind he will Castle queenside so he's uh
he's playing this quite well considering
I I gave up a piece for nothing the name
of the channel is almighty chest yeah
all my teachers okay III love you if I
can say that yeah why wouldn't you say
okay he expected me to play this wow
what a guy let's play yes no okay
I mean it's better like this but yeah
the queen is there for the taking I mean
it was either that this or that yawn you
you are looking strong do you go to the
gym yes I do go to the gym yes why to
strike fear in your opponent's eyes yes
when you play chess to move my pieces
more fiercely yeah and more fluidly yeah
as you could have seen now when I was
playing okay so that's a freak queen I
like it
okay that's even better let's go here he
was there it's a nice nice grab let's
grab this one mm-hmm okay well I wasn't
planning to have fun but it
you know it's just the way it is yes yes
yeah I think we'll have to go for
formate here as we're running okay we're
running very long time the game is going
in the corner the king is going places
all right good game sir the game woke up
nice I was uh hmm a one plus Oh mr.
cheeky blenders not picky bones but a
cheeky cheeky blunders all right since
we don't have a lot of time I don't mind
a few bullets
yes mr. cerium we saw the first picture
of the black hole we even discussed it
yeah but it's not this whole whole whole
picture
Tino shows me the entire one yeah this
is a zoomed versus yeah for some reason
they're showing that one
the original is much nicer yeah mr.
cheeky blunders is very cheeky taking
his time which I don't think is the way
to go in a bullet game yeah the bullet
game should really play play faster okay
well I should play faster as well so
play that yeah but just a nice and Brad
I might have seven men much better
another no it's not much better
yes no it's not after develop your
pieces as well look at this a juicy
Bishop okay this is very nice
okay after hiding one thanks beautiful
oh he wants to go for okay let's go this
he's gonna cover with the rook I'm gonna
go this way just a nice position to have
and enjoy which opening go to play which
opening that play I don't think it's
it's an actual opening so do play the
poem clothes or the evidence nope
yeah I'll just go here he's gonna push
the pawn I don't mind just grab that you
know as good as a knight as any should
maybe play faster but but I think
with this kind of place good enough yeah
okay thanks man
the queen is always good for okay let's
just easily calm that down okay the
night is here very nice okay let's go
here maybe push the pawn okay let's go
here okay okay okay
it was a cheeky cheeky blunder that one
well we have genes do do what I have the
next one
jion's okay okay ma'am
he's definitely Rokita twitter kiddush
okay he wants to go with b3 I'll I like
that
nice b3 move let's attack the knight I
was like giving up my bishop in a bullet
game so go here captures captures no all
right so you will have a bishop here yes
because I don't mind if it was a normal
game I would mind but since is bullet I
don't
okay let's go okay you might go f3 so
it's not a good move okay what okay I'll
give you that deaths might be considered
nice oh okay I don't know what was that
that was just weird okay
19:23 okay I'll play
sheesh so his name in the challenge
least three times but unfortunately not
acceptable whoa they're very nice
totally miss the dark square bishop
nicely done sir
oh the shoosh we are accepting bullet
challenges love so sorry for that aha
okay but he asked why
wasn't accepted haha alright we will
accept it
wow what a nice mate totally missed that
one
oh the king's gambit it was always
appreciated to be seen the greatest of
gambits and 9 of 6 that's always a
pleasure to see yeah that was a very
cheeky blunder ok tonight is it's coming
into the action not just that oh ok but
he is correct I mean you do play Queen
h4 check in one line of the King V on
this one okay so the bishop slicing like
a pie fish what what shushing yeah okay
that's been it good game let's see we've
seen him already
that's a one and a half what's that did
they play against him before I think you
owe mr. Martin Panda is here okay
that was really weird I missed that I
had a completely winning game and I
missed that nice checkmate that was
really cool
okay now we go a five I always like a
five did you say Knight is first yes
because this is bad but I I play it
nonetheless
whoa just because that's nice but
because the bishop the e3 was playing
the bishop cannot come to the honest
mirror I want to counter him on g6 like
whoa what's that nothing doesn't seem to
be anything okay let's transfer this guy
over here okay okay oh yeah it's a shame
but mr. Honda I did enjoy oh very nice
let's give this check here here I can
trade I mean
I'm down I'm up I'm up a piece so I will
consider trading yeah I don't mind okay
just trade it's a sneaky way to play but
it's a play for a wind yeah I mean I
don't have to oh very nice let's go here
beautiful check incoming okay that's a
pawn he might consider moving the rook
if he doesn't know he has to move your
room yeah but ok mr. Martin Fonda
refuses to move the rook
such a shame ok we have a 1 and a half
yeah nice triple pawns but it's it's
worth it if you wrap a piece I would say
oh the one I lost was a rated game oh
man
no that was in the tournament against
some cm oh yeah yeah true the first game
yeah ok yeah you can do that really
giving him everything well that's that's
what I want you to think okay I'm with
the bishop I'm really not now we do this
ok dangerous okay but I will grab ok
threatening this how does he do go about
this I'm on the run time not not
something I will complain about hmm ok
still gonna play this okay uh let's
even further maybe but not yet
let's get our our pieces into the game
he still has to develop let's go here
whoa did not expect the queenside castle
but I do like it I do like it ok I will
grab that wasn't planning to but I will
ok sure
hmm all right I like it if you really
consider moving my king
yeah could be could be a good idea and
now we can just enjoy like this so it's
a funky move because it doesn't do much
well but it's not a bad move
what does it do not much it doesn't do
much but it's a freaky move it's a move
that waste of time okay it makes you
think yeah okay what am i playing
against I'll take some of that action
I don't know what he's planning to do
here but okay I'm just gonna go this way
profile oh oh no I know I missed here
with my rook but that's what I had
planned you know no I'm gonna win the
night that's how I roll okay I wrote for
tonight okay
I have to get my Bishop into the game
that's for sure he's not gonna let me so
okay I'm sorry to see this but that's
what happens when you're low on lying
man i blunder a rook and then well then
just okay good game oh but he still
can't capture that doesn't matter
he can't capture but he's losing no but
he can't capture the pawn no no the
Queen the Queen yes but not the pawns
another pole still still still very nice
okay
okay let's do one more mr. ducek yeah
that was nice free moving really nicely
captain Nautilus says Yun take your
shirt and pants off please
okay see and that's not nearly as T as
the the right after the stream after the
stream ends all right mr. ducek doesn't
seem to be here
yep I think we're gonna have to abort go
for a second board okay life against the
Phoenix mmm and this could be his real
birth dear all right mr. Phoenix let's
do it
mr. Don downtown AV if Phoenix is here
okay he is let's where's the dog uh he's
beneath us
I believe well let's go for the nice
bedroom okay what was that all right
a nice pawn grab I would sacrifice a
pawn for activity yes in bullets that's
okay he's gonna go for queenside castle
which means I can just start pushing my
pawns garage the eight what why why sir
okay because of the beautiful knight on
d5 but is it beautiful it's the most
beautiful I still have my dark square
Bishop still hoping for him to somehow
find his way over there
I can maybe capture the night yeah let's
see if he figures out my plans before
but okay all right and just go like how
do i how do i trick him let's go here I
just want to do a nice trick I could
have done here but this this I like
better I will give you a hint for the
future
yeah go with the Queen on the side where
his king is not on the other side yeah
that's what that's what he's expecting
me to do in the last game you went to h4
also he canceled Queen sir
yeah yeah he's gonna go here doesn't
really matter let's grab some of that oh
that's where you planned the whole time
yeah but his King would still be here
okay not looking all too great here
he does have a nice past born but I
don't mind and we're both going to built
in second so really gonna have to what
is that whoa he didn't want it that's
weird
yeah okay oh that's a check well I will
get some of that action
all right and Phoenix rises my wrong car
okay I'll do you have enough yeah okay I
think this we played this one and one
more and I think that this will be it
for the stream okay okay not gonna go
for the early trade okay I should make a
deal stream would been fine gold yeah
maybe maybe maybe if he visits Croatia
while Madani there you go man
okay what's what's this oh it's a nice
trade but since this King is still in
the center I will say not happening so
yeah special but the King in the center
not gonna fly
okay this is just whoa some good stuff
happening yeah there's a lot of good
stuff yeah should have sacrifice
something there's time oh wow
that's really weird let's just grab that
Queen
it's nice Queen okay she doesn't want it
see how Wow Oh bye Johnny
Wow well I always say hi to all of my
viewers not just those from Azerbaijan
yes okay nice that is nice all right
that's a check all right we have time
for one more bullet I believe Souper
Salad I don't see already carefully yeah
where's the one Paso mr. that he's he
has a Bruno I always have to lose the
game against Bruno in the stream that's
all I will give Bruno a chance to play
yeah
all right Bruno let's let's roll it out
Bruno he played Brunei such a strong
place Bruno such a strong player I will
try to trick me with some sneaky moves
and go for the early I said there will
be a giveaway so okay
nope not giving you the bishop now
that's not happening Bruno Bruno such a
sneaky player what where do we go from
here not there I'll just try and see
what he what he wants to do keep the
weak D three point yeah let's just go
sit here okay I like a good look I like
it
these seven seems to be the square yeah
I don't like my position at all but
neither do I don't have to like it to
play it that's how really see how I
defend my pawn here I'm a natural crazy
now he can give up here but I
okay I'm that's uh that's an interesting
idea but I don't know it's always
interesting to play against Bruno such a
such a wild player yeah let's see what
he thinks about this he's gonna that he
can win a piece no he can't
he can go f4 I'm not worried about that
oh that's all the way and the night
hangs
right sir and I can't go neither three
unfortunately whoa we'll give a bit
quick I hope you put the Queen
okay I'm gonna win his queen so it
doesn't matter
I want his queen man really yeah oh my
god quickly no don't touch that born man
let's go here let's go here Oh
oh man what are you doing I'm trying to
checkmate him because he's getting the
Queen no such a beast all right
congratulations to Bruno and I believe
with this game we will end our stream
four hours have passed we had a very
nice tournament we had a nice nice
couple of challenges a nice giveaway so
that's that's about it
Congrats to Bruno for this wild game and
yeah that's it
anything you guys want to add for me
personally thanks for inviting me once
again I'm looking forward to the next
milestone I'm gonna meet you
hopefully it will come very soon because
I really enjoy the streams and yeah once
again congratulations to all the winners
to all of you guys joining I hope you
had a nice time and yeah yeah well
looking forward to the next one
yeah definitely teen chick Lenny last
word fun time watch anime alright guys
thank you very much for joining
we will now be having some soda and
that's about it yeah thank you guys for
joining we'll see you soon and if you
haven't seen it go check out my previous
video it's the one the the nicest game
well the brilliant surprising in from
the creation championship my star
Martina which organs are in your honor
is so to check it out if you haven't
really a couple Blancas like brilliance
is so I really do recommend it that's it
thank you all and I will see you soon